Two one and we're live.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a fight companion podcast.
What that means is if you've tuned in,
hoping to hear enlightening conversation or facts about the universe or ancient
civilizations,
Ron,
he comes to the wrong place pitches.
This is a bunch of people that shouldn't be awake but are awake.
5:00 AM I'm with a j Buddha,
Aka Eddie Bravo.
Kill a bee.
Ben Saunders is up in this bitch.
What's happening?
And then of course Brendan Motherfucking Shop,
Aka Big Brown,
Aka big,
Brown sexy.
And uh,
we here watching the UFC live from North Korea and the first fight is about to
happen Sam Sicilia versus do Ho choice.
I think it's Che.
I think they pronounce it Che.
Um,
but uh,
so if you've never heard these podcasts before,
what we do is we get together and we just watched the fights and we talk shit
and a,
we do a lot of the MMA world's journalism for them cause a lot of them,
they rely on us for stories.
What one,
those bitches are out there right now.
They're just waiting right now.
And we see pencils in their heads.
So tired,
cheeto fingers,
just fucking one.
One day,
this is one day when I'm tired of traveling,
this is what we're going to do.
This was fucking tough,
dude.
That was a hard one.
So I have a long ass day.
I gotta go to San Diego and teach a seminar.
And then after that seminar I got,
uh,
a friend of mine asked me to be in a music video.
So I'm doing that too,
like the chick from Whitesnake.
So last night I decided the only way I'm going to be able to pull this off is if
I go to sleep like at eight,
and like,
how the fuck am I going to go to sleep at eight?
I had a couple of ambiance,
so I took one ambien and I took it like around six 30 and I'm like feeling kind
of loopy.
And then he calls me,
he goes,
hey dude,
do you have another ambient?
I'm not gonna be able to sleep.
I'm like,
fuck,
you gonna have to drive over to my house.
He says,
Ben comes over,
by the time he comes over,
I'm fucking out.
He's not,
he's testing [inaudible] wake up two hours later,
I look at the text,
he's long,
God,
you must be out.
So I call him back.
I'm like,
Fuck Dude,
I'm sorry.
That ambien just crushed me.
So then he came back.
Did you actually come back?
Yeah,
I left it in my mailbox and uh,
but from that point on I couldn't go back to sleep.
I'm just sitting there and then I got really,
really medicated drowsy and then that was weird being all loopy on Ambien and
then stoned at the same time.
Dude,
I was breaking down some shit from when I was 15 like shit,
I was bringing back memories.
I never thought,
I'm like holy.
It was shut up all God damn night.
I didn't really get any sleep,
so I don't know how I'm going to do this.
I really don't.
Just hang in there baby.
He'd be fine.
Yeah.
That's good.
How long did you wait out?
Hey,
do you know what news?
Do you know what new were out?
Do you know what new vigil is?
Eddie?
New Vigil.
You ever heard of new vigil?
Some shit that fighter pilot's take.
It's uh,
it's something that,
um,
like they,
they,
I think they're official use for it is for people that have narcolepsy,
but it's,
um,
it's like a pill that helps you stay awake.
Like when you're really tired,
but it's not like speed.
It's real weird.
So notch understood.
But yeah,
we'll talk about some of that.
I know a dude.
I don't what,
that's going to be a hard fuck.
I gotta drive two hours after this homie.
You got this little costs.
We got plenty of these,
these caveman coffee,
one of these little fuckers has 240 milligrams of caffeine and that was,
that's a nicer than what I just drank.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
no,
that's just coffee.
It's pretty,
it is,
but it's not one of these nitro things.
Just
espresso shot.
It's like a double espresso or a triple espresso with some fucking nitrogen.
I don't know.
To try to explain to me how the Guinness of Toffee,
right.
This is a whole box.
Oh,
I love them.
I love these nitros but they're fucking super strong.
Like the rocket fuel.
240 is like a Venti Starbucks and it's all in this one little,
can Jim fuck,
how much is in a rock star?
Like one of those regular sized cans?
A good question because they break those bitches up and serving.
Do not consume all in one day and shit.
Dude,
you ever drank all those red lines?
Yes.
Those red lines.
I swear I was going to have a heart attack.
My heart was like a hummingbird man.
I'll never do it again.
Here we go.
Sam Cecillia Samsung cell.
You hit so hard.
That dude is,
he's an interesting character.
He's super game.
Sam Cecillia
tag.
We'll do that.
Good works for the birds.
Did you uh,
think everybody up with this or no,
I haven't.
Thank you Eddie.
Four minutes and 28 seconds right now of the first round with,
I think like I said,
it's,
it's spelled Troye but I think it's chick Christ.
See Sam Cecillia brings the thunder man.
I do.
It's fun.
The hell.
Yeah.
This is fun.
Oh Man.
Apricots.
He fights like with his hands,
way low,
and then you can just pass that joint around.
I'm not mad at you should do that.
And he's sitting there like he's smoking like a soul cafe cafe somewhere.
I told him so petty that you know isn't not the petty of today.
Does it lose it?
Oh Shit.
I tell you.
Oh,
snaps this spike brown.
He want some of this.
I know.
I'm
good man.
Scared of things could get weird.
I smoked that weird.
Do you want,
you want the headlines?
Let me smoke the house.
Let me smell it.
That at least the house.
We haven't talked publicly since the Rhonda fight.
No,
we have.
Oh dammit.
Enjoy that flight back to this day.
Oh my God.
He got cracked.
Fuck.
That was a crunk fight.
There was wild for the first round.
I'm not magic guys.
Turtle Neck and Korea.
Damn those people.
Let me super psyched.
A Korean guy wants to Korea and knocked the fuck racist Cilia.
No,
they like it.
Hell yeah.
It's not racist.
It's okay to be racist like at sporting events,
right?
No,
it's not okay to be racist,
but you can be proud to be from a country.
Exactly.
You can hate the other guy since he's not from your country.
That was when,
um,
I forget who it was,
but when,
um,
uh,
what the fuck is his name?
God dammit.
Mike Pie was fighting.
I'm trying to remember his name.
Uh,
he fought this cat in Brazil and a Funche I think it was fun and he knocked him
out and uh,
it was just a straight clean victory.
Everything is good.
No poor sportsmanship.
Everything was great.
Said Nice things,
the post fight interview,
but all they're doing is chanting something.
The whole crowd's chanting something.
I can't figure out what their Channing,
so I asked the translator and he says,
they're basically chanting the Brazilian version of you're a faggot.
Oh Damn.
The whole crowd,
the whole crowd,
like 15 to Brazil doesn't fuck around.
When I,
when I forgot Nogueira crowd was chanting wants the same thing.
They're chanting.
One day I was like,
damn,
I'm old.
Fuck it.
Hit out here man.
I turned her on to my coach speaks Portuguese.
I go where they say and he's like,
you really want to know?
I'm like,
fuck yeah.
He goes,
they're chanting,
you're going to die.
I was like,
God,
dog.
That's intense because that's her thing.
[inaudible] that's where lax on that.
Imagine if the American crowds are chanting that that guy looks like a star
craft champion.
He looks like a dude who would,
you know beat your ass at some new video game.
He doesn't look very guy.
Well,
no,
he fucks him.
Sam Cecillia by knock.
He looks like he's just a beast with the Rubik's cube or some shit.
I'd like when dudes are unassuming like that,
but are murderers like,
hi,
I know Kenny Florida,
like Kenny the type dude you would fuck with in a bar.
Right?
He's small,
huge head,
sexy beard launch.
Fuck.
What the fuck are you with your watch kid?
He's been through some shit.
You're fucking watch and your nice tie asshole loses his whole face.
Fuck,
fuck you up man.
I know.
He's like the most unassuming ass kicker.
He looks like an accountant,
but he will jack your world up,
man.
You would just realize like really early on,
what a mistake it was when you started jab like,
Oh shit,
this guy does he get to fuck.
I had a buddy of mine who um,
work a,
he was a bouncer
at a strip club and he was a purple belt under hoists.
This is back in the late nineties.
And he was a,
he was a dickhead and he would go out and start fights and he would go out with
a knee pads on and ties and he would work with ties.
It were velcro.
You just pull them off and he's ready to go psycho.
Yeah,
he is.
He's a psycho and he fucked people up really easy.
I've seen him fuck people up at the Strip club.
Like it just like,
just like in Gracie and action.
Take the dude down.
His guard easily mount to me,
gives us back,
chokes him out.
And uh,
he walked up,
he,
he did that to some guy right in front of me and said,
that's all you got.
And then he stands,
it goes nice fight asshole.
He was all mad because it was too easy.
That's his amateur record man.
But he had some road rage and he flipped some dude off and do flipped him off
and he pulled over and he fought some guy and he said it went on for like 20
minutes goes man.
The dude knew Jujitsu was fucking hard it because I think he won [inaudible]
minutes
stuff back and forth.
Barn burner,
right?
No Mace.
No.
We're just all clenched up probably,
you know on the ground and the dirt just clinched up with problems.
This guy knows how to fight.
This goes to loose a blue belt.
You start talking to them at that point.
Come on bitch,
what are you training?
If you get to a good spot,
we have card.
Everybody knows her.
[inaudible] what does this sport,
what is it?
What is the name of the push street sports in Santa Monica.
CanNot the mog.
No old school
is calling out to all his friends in the starcraft clan.
We still meet for Land Party,
Dude.
The thing is that high surgery,
why?
Oh,
you mean that thing with your eyes that they tried to an Americanized,
right.
It's so normal.
They're super normal.
It's not really craft champion.
It's like chicks with fake tinnitus.
It's like having your period with Jamie put up on the big screen on the little
screen on the left.
That's a,
let's do like the best video game play in the world or some shit and starcraft
champion.
Yeah.
That's the starcraft champion.
Look at Korean Zombie.
I forgot about him.
He's military.
Two years.
Mandatory military service.
You don't fuck around man.
It's almost over though,
right?
I think so.
You know that's an interesting thought in the military right there.
Yeah,
he is.
He's got a suit on military,
so he does kidding.
She was rolling with that role.
I'm sure he's still training.
No,
I didn't see it was a viral role.
Ben Henderson and the Korean Zombie and when was this?
How long ago?
A couple of days ago.
It's all over the net.
This was he is he out here?
The Korean Zombie Puts Ben Henderson in a twister,
but he escapes and then pin hips and comes back and meat hooks.
The Shin,
rubber guards this shit out of him.
Sick and puts them into Omoplata.
Yeah.
How's this capsule?
How Berto,
MENA,
how's this guy?
11 to know undefeated.
Why did I nasty as trying to remember when I saw it?
Yeah,
it's a beautiful moment.
I'm not mad at.
So where have I seen him fight before?
They're trying to figure out who he fought.
Do Korean zombies walk out when he comes out to crane bay?
Oh here it is.
There it is.
Up on the screen.
Koreans.
Oh yeah,
there it is.
And where were you guys?
Damn,
Jamie's on fire.
Look at their video taping this role.
Like it's some serious shit.
A bunch of people there.
Right?
Look at that.
That's like Abu Dhabi.
You're going to put cameras on there.
You can't just roll light.
It's a real shit.
Now they kind of did cause he kinda like gave him a triangle.
I don't think it's as though this isn't the role I saw or it's a different angle
too.
Didn't have gloves.
This wasn't the,
Oh,
they're just messing around here.
Yeah,
this ain't the one,
Jamie.
God dammit you.
That's some bullshit.
So they're just sort of a slap it on each other.
They're just a nice sweat for Ben for Fight Week,
Huh?
Oh,
uh,
if,
if you were Ron as head coach,
how would you have her train for the rematch?
And what'd you do?
She was going to listen to you.
She was all in your hands.
What would you tell her?
This is what you gotta do is on Mba.
Oh God.
I thought we were talking about
you guys are [inaudible] with the interview question.
Interview question.
Stone cold.
Hey,
you know,
you used to date this girl,
she's,
you know,
whatever,
the superstar athlete,
whatever.
How would you train it bro?
You too,
Bro.
I'll tell you what's interesting is people think it's that easy.
We can just go find another striking coach and everything.
It doesn't work like that.
Of course not.
But what would you do you have,
do you have six months?
What'd you do,
six months of strategy be?
And what would the training be like?
Well,
listen man,
six months you,
you need to cut out all the drama in your life.
Probably find a new coach and uh,
just focus on what you do because she's never going to out strike Holly.
That's never happening in this world ever.
Even if you gave her two years.
So do what you do.
You don't need to read,
reinvent the wheel,
but your best chance of winning is by grappling.
So you're not going to invest your whole time trying to compete with a world
class striker.
So what would you do?
You'd hook her up with the rest of them.
Call,
try it and just all the commercial,
just see a Rhonda,
no more focused,
met commercials with all that Shit.
They should just be wrestling and double light commercial.
That's where the UFC and her camp fucked up.
Kept everyone kept calling Mike Tyson.
She had her striking with Mike Tyson,
I guess,
man,
I guess so.
So she has this striking Mike Tyson.
She had that Mike Tyson or,
because she kept greeting girls but agree because everyone was so sold on the
striking,
including me.
I thought she looked real good against Batchko hail.
But batch go hand is like more of a brawler style.
And when,
when Holly,
when,
when Ronda comes like super aggressive like that,
that'll work on a lot of girls that'll fold under that pressure.
All of,
but Holly,
Holly just rose to the,
he's the only one who's had real perfect foot work.
And the way the fight started when Ron Ron is that they're looking at each other
and hall,
he just kept skipping to the left,
skipping to the right,
skipping,
skipping of the right.
No one's ever done that to her.
She was doing look at my foot,
but I'm just going to be damned if you watch it.
You notice that she did that from the moment she entered the ox
four.
If you watch Holly's previous sites swishy or boxing fights or championship
fights,
she didn't do before.
But if you do your research on the Hollywood,
you know,
I'm a victim of it too.
I was like,
yeah,
I,
I thought Rhonda was going to win.
Didn't I say on this podcast?
I go,
dude,
Rhonda didn't,
I dunno what I said word for word,
but I did.
I did say that.
Uh,
I didn't see Adam predict shit.
No,
no one did.
No one fucking
hilarious is how many people are talking shit.
Now I know there's so,
there's so mean about it,
but like you didn't see this common way to go shop.
Wait,
good call on that one.
Oh my patterning hold the fucking huge upset in the UFC.
The amount of fucking means,
oh my gosh.
She broke the internet crazy.
She's only been doing Stan or she's only been doing MMA for four years.
Like a little more than four years.
He shouldn't have life experience,
which is nuts because she's 34 right?
It's true.
Oh,
you were talking about Holly Holm.
We see the amount of fights that she's had though.
Boxing and kickboxing and then you see that footwork and those combos that she
landed in that fight like man,
she,
she had a split decision victory over a cow,
Paddington.
It was so real close fight and so that she goes from that fight to the Marion
were no fight,
which is a really good fight.
She looked good in that fight and then this fight,
she's just looked like a world beater.
I think just,
you know,
fight through all about matchup study as,
and I think,
I think Amanda and Holly fight a hundred times.
Holly probably wins at least 95 I just think style wise it's a bad match up.
So I don't think so.
If she focused like she did on her striking,
keep working,
striking.
She's still got obviously a lot to work on,
but she's got a really take her wrestling to the highest possible levels per
shits on the ground.
You got to get the fight to the ground.
You can't make it a kick,
but he's never been taken yet.
You got to wrestle,
wrestle and if you can't wrestle then we got to pull guard Holly's.
Yeah,
maybe that's it.
That's it.
There's only three choices you could strike with her.
You could try to take her down if those two don't work because the strike is not
going to work and if the rest of them don't work,
all you have left is pulling guard.
Good luck.
Why is that?
It's Holly Holm submitted in some anti guard pulling.
She has a,
she works.
She works very hard on grappling it and know what I'm saying is,
is she a master at an Tigard pulling?
You said good luck trying to good luck cause there's Rhonda Mastered Guard.
Polar does Rhonda back.
She'd have to figure out how to do it all.
You got to,
it's because you shoot
all the time.
It's not that hard.
That's his thing.
Exactly.
She's got to make it her thing.
She's got to get the fight to the ground.
If the wrestling ain't going to work,
if the judo ain't going to work,
what do you,
what else do you have left?
Stand with her.
That's already not going to work.
So you only join.
He only joined the rounds are took our employee.
There's
no one cared.
People that expect it.
Ryan Hall to do it when right.
All pull guard and he tapped two dudes out by pulling guard.
It happens all the time.
That's how.
How's it working for Ryan Hall on the ultimate fighter though?
No,
he lost his last fight.
You know what?
When I was really impressive.
Ryan Hall is,
Matt is a striking and his foot work pretty damn legit man.
It's getting better.
Yeah.
If he just keeps going,
Ryan Hall could be a serious threat.
His strikings on its way to being pretty damn good and,
and my fucking opinion,
what do I know I could Jeet Kun doe for two and a half years.
I think you definitely a right about her needing more options for being able to
take guys down.
It's a question of like how long would it take for her to pick up those other
options because she's always looking for the same thing.
She's always looking for the clinch and up until now that's all she's had to do.
She clenches with girls and she's just a superior grappler.
She wants a hip toss and them throwing them on the ground in spectacular
fashion,
beating their ass and arm Barnum and that's what she's been doing.
But if you can't do that,
and she didn't have those other options.
I tried out for doubles.
I mean does she,
does she ever do that?
[inaudible]
you know she's been doing judo since she's was in a diaper,
right?
Her knees aren't great either.
You know,
she said to me,
so for say,
okay,
now,
now go freestyle,
wrestle.
Let me know how that goes.
Try and fucking freestyle wrestle.
Holly Holm.
If everyone has all these kind of ideas on what she should do,
it's tough man.
So you lose your eye.
What would you think?
Would you think she has to do what she's always done,
but just do it better and more focused?
You got to do what got you to the dance.
I think you take out the negativity in your life.
You get a coach who's,
who's going to support you and you put worldclass string around you and you
bring to what got you to the dance.
You don't try to cross the hobby type coach,
right?
Matt Hume.
You come up with someone Delphia Greg Jackson.
Cause that's how it,
you know,
that's her guy.
But you need someone to come up with a game plan where we're going to take your
tools that have got you to this point and we're going to try to implement that
with the Lilly because right now that's not happening right now.
Right now the game plan,
uh,
dash forward and let's try and get her arm.
But you know,
fuck man,
when Dana talked about,
he was like,
if it ain't broke,
don't fix it.
Like that's how he was looking at the fucking at our training,
you know?
And I'm like,
I get that up until now.
But now you look at that fight and he got to go.
Okay,
well there's obviously Holly has a way in.
I mean,
and Holly has a pretty clear path to victory countering if,
if Rhonda keeps going forward like she did in that fight,
how you will keep cowering or to the end of time,
I think what Ron and needs to do is look around and anyone,
including Dana,
it says,
no,
you're good.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
Fuck you.
See Ya.
I need to change this up.
Tom Surrounded by yes men and everyone thinks everything's all good and everyone
that goes,
no,
she didn't get hurt in the fight.
There's no concussion.
Oh God,
fuck are you talking about who said she got line?
Who said there's no concussion?
Who has a lot?
A lot of people
they go,
no injuries.
Cause I saw,
I get fucking flatline.
She checked it.
She got so anyone who says no,
no,
everything's all good.
You don't need to change anything.
That should be an indicator for her to go.
All right,
you're out of the crew.
I think technically maybe,
maybe there's some personal issues and stuff,
but technically she hasn't been striking that lung.
So technically she's at a great spot with their striking.
She lost because of pride and strategy.
That's it.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
Why you say sweaty?
Say Pride.
Because she wanted to get up there and throw down.
She didn't,
she didn't win when she clearly lost round one,
she didn't come out thinking
she had no other option.
She goes already lit up.
You also got to realize this isn't like a buster Douglas,
Mike Tyson.
You what I'm saying?
Like she,
she just didn't get clipped.
She got out classed.
It was even close.
He looked cheek approach.
She was down to strike with it.
She got lit up when she was,
she has to be.
She was like,
I'm sure the game.
Oh No,
no.
After she tried taking her down,
then it's like,
fuck man,
I have to stand with this guy and that's your only option.
What did you think about the advice that she was getting in her corner?
She didn't back up.
She went full.
It's tough to say because you're talking about pride,
you know what I mean?
A prime,
maybe not in a bad way.
You know?
Maybe even a ten eight round like she got fund up.
You and your coach because you're doing great.
This is exactly where we want her.
What the fuck?
What are you talking about man?
What the fuck are you going straight again?
For sure.
That's when you're surrounded by yes.
Men.
Sony's looking,
I'm like,
fuck man.
I listen.
We need footwork.
Control the distance.
Try it and get your underhook and go to work,
but what you're doing right now,
don't rush in there with your hands down and your jaw wide open,
you're going to get kicked in your face.
Do you think that she was just so dominant that no one around her thought this
could ever happen?
Do you think that's a possibility?
Yes.
I think everyone including uh,
you know,
a ton of people in our circle thought there's no way this could ever happen.
She can get away with whatever she wants.
When the first round ended and she looked tired,
like what do you think that that tired is from the beating that she took in that
round?
Or do you think it's,
is it a combination or is it being out of shape because it having too many
distractions?
No,
I,
the one thing about Rhonda is no Ma you,
she could be filming eight movies and she's going to come in shape.
That's one thing she can control herself.
She's a monster.
Her work ethic is like no one else's.
So I don't think it's a matter of for being not shape.
I just think for the first time she's like,
man,
I got fucked up.
And that's a different feeling because your,
your adrenaline's pumping.
You're getting fucked up
chasing a girl.
So I just don't think she's ever been.
Then they isolated in the truck.
They isolated this one elbow.
She hit Rhonda with where Rhonda is moving forward.
She steps in and left elbows are on the chin.
It's like,
I can't believe she didn't break her job because we seen that first round her
mouth wide open,
which I've never seen and usually that's a broken job,
but are you sure it's not broken?
Because that was the big room and that keeps going around.
It's a huge room and then he's really,
we see her,
I didn't see it,
but I hear she,
when she got off the plane from lax,
you know there's pop Razzi she's covering her face.
Right.
We'd seen her face get busted up and she probably didn't want to talk to them.
They're saying,
man,
yes,
but I don't know,
man.
That's tough.
It's a such a historic event.
I mean if she would have went right through Holly,
that fight would have been fucking forgotten.
That would have been one of those.
Did you know random fights?
If she would've just went right through her instead,
that's a moment in time that will go on forever.
It's also a buster Douglas,
it's also a martial arts lesson.
It's a lesson in martial arts.
It's the lesson and approach.
Like if you get your,
you take away the personalities and the stardom and the friendship,
all the stuff that you have for those people and you just look at it as like two
components,
like two,
two numbers interacting with each other.
Just to look at it like completely objective.
What you see is like one strategy that's really effective with one type of
movement,
like when really refined movements,
worldclass movement,
foot work and then angles and understanding the technique like super well and
another.
You see the super determined athlete who's been very dominant but just the
numbers aren't adding up and as the round goes up she's further and further in a
deficit because she keeps getting cracked and then Holly keeps cut.
And then your confidence wanes.
It has to.
There's no doubt,
right?
There's the frustration.
There's the numbers of time that she's getting hit.
There's a lot of things like factoring in and it all leads up to that insane
head kick we see in exhausted,
but still aggressive Rhonda,
and when Holly pushes her and then boom sets up that left high kick,
you're like,
that's a martial arts lesson that this can have straight up.
This can happen to anybody.
Anybody,
man.
That's why.
That's why fighting so different than other sports can happen to anyone.
For me,
I hated to see it,
man.
I liked seeing greatness.
You know what I'm saying?
I love seeing greatness.
While we saw it,
we saw it in Holly.
That was greatness.
This is an opportunity for Rhonda to Shell Harbor Percent Greatness and the,
again,
it's all about matchups.
Holly has some tough fights besides Ronda.
Miesha Tate's a hell of a fight for Holly.
There's those cats and Ghana cats in Ghana.
These aren't,
these aren't just going to dominate man.
No.
So I think it's good for the sport,
but also Holly's also a person that you could tell if you have young daughters,
you want him to be like Holly,
great person,
amazing person,
just a nice person.
We can't get her.
The media cannot get her to talk shit about Rhonda.
She's just a great person.
Even when Ron goes a long way in their face at the weigh ins,
I asked her,
she's like,
wow,
I was just trying to have a drink here and there.
Like after Ronda went crazy on her,
she like didn't even respond back like fuck you bitch,
you're the fucking fake.
You fucking take damage.
She didn't,
none of that.
She,
she's been in world home fights,
you know,
multiple times.
So to her it was like,
all right,
let's do it man.
You know there's also like she had two other fights in the UFC,
the first one,
which is like the octagon shock fight.
I'm always willing to kind of throw out the first fight.
UFC jitters.
Yeah.
Just like so many people.
That's just such a big moment.
And they go,
man,
next time I get it now I'll just go in there and fight my fight.
And then the second fight was marrying her.
No,
she looked way better,
look much better.
But this fight is like,
she must have put in just mad hours and been more focused and more determined
for this and just had an incredible camp and had a game plan is stuck to the
plan man.
Like that first round dude,
she never stopped moving,
never stopped executing the game plan.
Even took Rhonda Down when she does Rhonda down.
I was like,
what the hell?
How many of uh,
the,
the other two fights I didn't get to see,
but uh,
did her opponents stop coming forward or at least stand still or move backwards?
So they're not really decision close.
Rodney kept coming to all the time.
Well we know where it came forward like Rhonda did.
No one does.
No one does because Ronda comes forward like a demon.
She comes forward like Vandelay Silva and [inaudible] comes forward so hard that
uh,
that moment happened where it looked like a matter of one.
You know what I mean?
That's how hard she was calming.
That's what made her look ridiculous.
That's what made it look ridiculous cause she's trying so hard in college.
Like what,
what are we doing?
Holly's just on a completely different level when it came to our standup and for
her to come in and that great shape and that focus like she was for that fight.
You got to see everything she's capable of,
which I don't think we've ever seen inside the octagon Winkle.
John was saying that,
uh,
they laid back and that like she didn't show everything in our first two fights
on purpose.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's crazy.
Like if she really like took it easy on purpose to set up the fight with Ronda
and then uncork all of our talent and that one fight it,
I was ever done that I remember being at that being true.
It could,
it could be totally,
dude.
I wouldn't be true cause Holly striking so much better and everyone's,
it could be true.
I remember being at Jackson's and the room stopping to watch Holly Spar Dude's
uh,
other girls and just murking bitches up.
Wow.
Yeah.
Just merkin girls up man.
And like I said,
look,
couldn't,
could not happen to a nicer person.
Isn't it an interesting no,
but you knew all that and yet you still thought that Rhonda was going to be tail
man,
I'm,
I'm part,
I'm the guy who got honey,
Dick and I,
and I'm balls deep in this UFC game outside of my black belt in the UFC game and
I,
I was like,
oh no.
I even,
I think it's that on this.
So I said,
I'm much though.
Yeah,
I think Rhonda is going to win,
but if you look back at Holly's fights,
like I've been going back like Holly's fights.
Yeah,
man.
No Shit.
It was just a perfect storm.
Both those tools,
UFC fights threw everybody off.
Especially the first one.
We're cal painting by the way,
is tough as fuck.
Super time.
She's also,
she's sneaky.
She's not going to just charge straight out.
You like that.
She makes it a little bit more difficult then you factor in the nerves and
again,
the Mirin Reno fight,
she looked way better.
She definitely looked,
hey,
she got fight of the night for that I think or think.
I think it was one of the performances of the night.
I don't know if it was fight of the night or what,
but she um,
in the Rhonda fight though,
she was,
it was 100% 110%.
I don't think we do.
I don't think we've ever seen a fighter,
male or female in their prime,
this big of a superstar get out class like that.
No,
no we haven't.
We've seen people get caught.
We like got fucked.
They'll be back.
We've never seen where like,
oh shit.
She got dismantled from the bell from the beginning.
She just got to focus on taking her down.
That's it.
No sense in her.
She also has to focus on just fighting.
I mean she made a movie,
she's,
she's going to make roadhouse like a female roadhouse.
She's got all sorts of other shit going on.
Sony,
Sony's to tell him,
can you imagine if name anyone else?
Granted,
I realize Rhonda is leaps and bounds ahead of a lot of the girls,
but she's finally met a girl who she's not.
So Holly's not on this track to make Origami.
All he wants to be is a world champ of the UFC.
Came at Jeff,
uh,
Verdomme or Cain Velasquez or Chris Weidman.
We're making movies than trying to defend their belt and then would get fucked
up.
You know,
it's crazy.
Can you imagine Patrick Code tables doing movies?
You'd be like,
I'm gonna fuck this dude up.
I used to love seeing that.
When I see my guy doing something on the side,
I'm like,
dude,
he's about to get fucked up.
Cause while he's balls deep in this script,
I'm training my ass off.
Meanwhile,
sexy Yama looks fucking great.
This guy knew,
I didn't know he was fighting on this card.
I mean you're talking about duties or pride veteran,
his fucking standup books sharpish shit tonight.
His body's on point.
It's Annette Tans always on point.
You know,
he sells out arenas.
Seems does look at me.
Do you know that is the voice of an angel?
No,
he's not an angel body of a God voice of an angel body of a God.
That's pretty crazy.
He's a huge singing star and Japan.
That's crazy.
It is.
Korea.
Is he still a huge star over there?
Picked your street ass on your case then he's like,
no,
he's not a one hit wonder.
Well,
jet Japan's beach like that with a like just abandoned stuff.
Like they were really into MMA for a while.
Like it was huge.
Like they used to sell at the site,
Thomas Subaru arena and then they're like,
ah,
not anymore.
We're good.
Good.
It's not like,
you know like football in the u s will never die.
Never.
Something would have to be,
even with all the concussion info and this deal's good myth movie,
people like Blah Blah,
blah,
whatever,
whatever.
100%.
Nobody gives a fuck.
They give up,
they give up.
They don't give a fuck.
What weren't they super into like a cut like country western.
It's like been catching last one hillbilly type shit dressed up like Elvis.
They abandoned.
So don't,
can't you buy like a old underwear in the vending machines?
You can see I've never been over there.
To me it's a fucking different world in the early two thousands Japanese are
really,
and to have an Afro's ones.
It was really cool.
Now,
the models,
when you take an or white dude or an Asian dude and give him an Afro,
what is involved in that process?
It was a five minute Ben.
Do you remember,
were you just like,
God sent some work?
Who at an Afro?
He fought Rico Rodriguez in pride.
He ended up dying,
but I forget his name.
He was a book house to Cerro Japanese with us,
Bro.
He fought in pride.
He fought Rico Rodriguez.
I remember that.
It's called a perm.
Forget his name.
Correct.
How did he die?
I don't remember.
But uh,
he's done
recipes.
Good fucking sexy Yama looks man.
Is this a middleweight fight or is this a welterweight fight?
Has to be,
well,
is he
tan like from a booth?
That's,
that's a good gold tan son.
He could easily be from Laos.
Yeah,
right.
He's one of them.
Chocolate,
Asians,
one of those dudes,
Bruce Lee [inaudible],
who's got a better body than Akiyama.
It's kind of like the best body of all time.
There's only,
there's one guy who I might give it to over him and that's Woodley Woodley.
His body up on chocolate is the best ass Woodley.
That's a bubble.
But I know I sound weird here,
but Willie's packings a beat back their
silence,
but to what car?
One had a fucking honeydew melon back
to bowing out of fucking ghetto booty.
Let them gorilla little booties,
the zoo.
And you see the silver bag waddling around.
You put cheeks to fucking water knowns.
You put a thumb on Darwin,
man.
He bent over like God damn son.
That's a hairy ass.
Your ass Nicki Minaj it homeboy sexy.
I'm gonna get kicked in the jewels.
Oh No.
Oh.
He looked like he kicked him in the nuts.
Nobody kicked anybody.
I'm going me see this shit kick.
Oh,
he grazed the helmet.
bars.
Shit.
Ooh,
I bet you he is packing heat.
Giant Dick.
Just a big old angry fucking Korean Dick.
Hey,
you think seeing nothing
last Samurai,
Gog Magic's
sayings when he pulls his dick out.
Imagine all the pussies.
I believe he's married with a family.
Eddie Bravo.
How about you?
Just back off.
Who the built or just doing work?
He's like fucking Godzilla.
Probably Ganga is Khan in the whole country.
Didn't get 'em down.
Fucking building this guy like he must be just like lifting weights all the
time.
All the time.
There's no other way.
Like it's not normal for a fight or beautiful like that.
I agree.
I mean when you're doing wrestling,
Jiu Jitsu,
kickboxing,
it's hard to keep up a physique.
Like that hundred percent liquid.
His haircut too.
That's gotta be natural.
No Way.
He's on pills,
right?
Well I dunno man.
Oh comment.
But the bottom line about juice is those guys that fought in pride like they
definitely could have then.
So what weight class would they have?
Those good question.
I think he was wanting 85 I think he was in vandelays weight class.
Right?
Oh Shit,
dude.
For people are like,
oh,
steroids aren't that big of a deal.
Thank [inaudible] big foot too.
There's so such a big deal.
Oh my gosh.
Such a big deal.
It's such a big deal.
So when women take them,
you know,
I mean that's,
that's even sometimes more of a big deal.
I agree.
That's a,
you know,
I bet it was reading this thing about what happens to women bodybuilding.
Oh,
he's getting,
oh yeah.
He got them in the back of the headers year.
He got a tag,
but he keeps moving.
Maybe a mean.
Yeah.
Good luck getting out of alive when you beat up the fucking national icon.
Fuck up his same voice.
Hey Ratko.
He's done.
He has a singing career.
You asshole.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Oh God.
I made it out of the round praise.
Akiyama third round.
No,
I don't think so.
Yeah.
We don't know.
Damn.
This dude is on really paying attention.
He is fucked up.
Damn.
His body's distracting.
So I was reading this thing about female bodybuilders in the permanent effects
it has on them when they like you imagine that girls take male hormones just to
get jack like a dude in their underwear and pose on stage.
Like you literally change your physiology.
Essentially.
You Go,
you shift way over to the male side.
There's no coming back,
right?
Yeah.
Like you're not just on no.
Come on.
Gang cycle of steroids.
Dude's Jalan,
you know tidies everything changes,
changes.
Their frame changes,
their bone structure take.
But I think if you take a hormones,
it takes seven years to get back to where you will.
So you would have to take,
like you could change your body in seven years.
You'd have to take like female hormones.
That makes sense.
That's how transsexuals do it.
A transsexual man takes male or it takes female hormones then becomes more
feminine over time.
But seven years now to see the thing of,
they're saying that,
but I don't know if it's different.
21 years you could go back in there.
Yeah,
but I don't know if it's different.
What if there's on that?
I don't know if it's different.
I don't know if it's different with a women,
like if it goes women to men or men and women.
It's the same if it's the same pace,
but they're saying that when a man goes to a woman doctor,
Ramona Kraits,
I think her name is [inaudible],
she,
they interviewed her for us.
Stephie Crooklyn interviewed her about Fallon Fox.
And one of the things they were saying is when you take estrogen,
it actually preserves bone density.
So like,
yeah.
Yeah,
because like that's why women,
when they get older,
they develop osteoporosis.
So this idea that like taking the estrogen is automatically,
and they give you like lower bone density,
like,
uh,
like uh,
a woman of Shit back Yemen.
They're still thrown down.
That's not necessarily the case.
So if you had a woman that took testosterone,
got like more manly,
right?
And then start taking estrogen,
like it just doesn't necessarily mean it would shrink her gold structure back
down.
Cause it's very tricky.
It's very tricky because there's a cycle to that shit.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot going on in your body.
Like they're all interconnected.
That's why when dudes take steroids,
they get bitch tits.
Like your body's like,
hey fuck face.
Like what's,
what's,
what all his testosterone.
I'm going to give you tidies cause yeah,
cause all your testosterone,
then your body goes up.
We need estrogen imbalances.
Your body is like,
you've got way too much test you fucking crazy deck.
Enjoy these tits.
Yeah.
Joy.
I'm joining his tits to.
These guys are going off.
Meanwhile sexy Yama has survived.
Fuck yeah.
Good man.
Yeah man.
Hell yeah.
He's looking good in this,
this round in consideration.
The fact that he almost got stopped just two minutes ago.
Dude,
he has a salty STFC record.
Dude.
He's been around for a long time.
That your ass,
but remember one Vito lit him up.
Oof like a Christmas tree in Times Square.
Fuck.
Hey Victoria Anderson Silva.
Hom Brazil.
Goodness.
Oh my goodness.
What a fight for sure.
Just let them both juice to the gills.
He can't walk.
Yeah,
you're right.
Probably I want like Margaret Beier,
Sammy Sosa,
Shit.
That left leg is Jack my five Akiyama with the fucking white tie.
Bang Bang.
Damn.
What a crazy fun cards mean.
Fucking good.
So did you see that thing that I'm Victor Conte tweeted,
dude,
I,
I walked.
I could literally,
it was like,
is this real life that I sent you?
Then I sent it to you.
I said,
is this real life the thing about Holly Holm?
Oh yes.
Most with Eddie.
You know what we're talking about?
Nah,
this is ridiculous.
Victor Conde tweeted this thing where some bodybuilding expert zoomed in on
Holly Holmes crotch zoomed in on her bikini's and was like the zoomed in on her
where her vagina is and they're trying to say that she has clitoral hypertrophy
based on her Moose snuggle.
Yes,
exactly.
[inaudible] Moose knuckle.
That's amazing.
It's so stupid.
Oh Shit.
Fuck.
Akiyama I'm gonna get the leg core
Victor Conte to tweak that out.
It takes the credibility away from him.
I couldn't believe.
I'm like,
first of all,
you don't know what it looked like before.
Like you're basing this on what you,
just the way it looks like women's Vagina Lips are quite different.
The people are just haters.
Man was world champion.
Now,
where were you before you,
this is like a Wayne photo.
Yes.
The way in photo of her,
so they just zoom in like weigh in on the box.
She wasn't born with those things.
They're just trying to hate on her.
Mary,
she's the champ.
Some chicks don't talk to too.
She's the preacher's daughter,
but his son of a bitch.
It's like,
I was watching this.
I was like,
is this real life to Victor Conte?
Really tweet this v you just sent me the link.
I just thought it was some bull shit.
Then he sent it in an email too.
I think I got it.
Anyway,
I got it in an email blast from him and I got it in a tweet.
I was like,
Whoa,
really dude,
I won't even entertain that bullshit.
It's so silly.
So silly to even say something like that.
You know?
If it's one thing to have someone who believed that,
but it's another thing for a guy like Victor Conte to tweet it.
We have some credibility,
right?
He's known as a snitch on everyone.
Well doing.
He was one of the guys at Balka,
but he wasn't like a scientist.
Right.
He was just like a sort of a marketing guy.
Yeah.
All our king guy behind it.
This is so crazy.
This guy missed the shot and oh shit.
Oh
Shit.
He didn't give me a chance to get up.
There's a guy in the NFL,
his name's Landry,
if you've ever seen this one yet.
You know what I'm talking about,
Jamie?
His arms are,
he's fucking Jack,
so he's been caught three times for steroids and this last time they're like,
Bro,
just so he served a 10 game suspension.
He gets off the suspension.
He knows he's going to be tested again.
Hot Positive for steroids.
Just can't not take him.
He's fucking jacked man.
I see.
I was always under the impression that everyone in the NFL was on steroids.
There's so big.
I was like,
when you see it,
350 pound person like that he's had,
he looked at that picture,
look at the screen off Jesus came and he supposed to be fast and quick.
God,
look at his arms.
He's a fucking monster.
Those arms are retarded.
He's probably like one of the biggest guys arms I've ever seen.
Old Ones.
Now he's on,
he's on team fucking sit at home.
He's on the,
he's on the same team as I am.
So dude like that,
right?
Like he's obviously taking him for football,
Once you get gigantic for who can you get that big without doing juice?
I don't think so.
And that Lien,
Right?
So when you see all those gigantic fucking dudes that are playing for the NFL,
some of them are gotta be genetics,
right?
100%.
There's,
I've seen some guys who are just complete freaks where people chalk it up to
steroids,
but it's not,
they're just genetically different than we are.
But are they like ridiculously ripped and big or they liked the lineman that are
no,
no.
Like my best friend Joe cloth had Stein.
He's six,
six to 76% body fat just woke up like that.
Jesus Christ just woke the fuck up like that.
I was with them last night and he just balls deep in donuts.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And then I tried it fucking,
yeah,
I can't do that.
Wow.
Look at that.
They're going to make a gift of her to get crazy.
Yeah.
That will be on that harrowing
Yama.
Sexy Yama.
We get Bruce buffer call on the first round.
It's a good question.
We were talking.
Okay.
For sure.
Akiyama one,
there's no way he's going to lose this.
That just doesn't happen.
And uh oh the action they bring in judges?
No,
really an Asian.
He,
it's part of the deal up.
Ah Fuck we are shelves or draw that guys.
That was a Chinese judge.
Oh dare you.
How dare you.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
I mean the third round he looked like dog shit rounds.
Two and three were both ten eight rounds in my opinion.
Do you think?
Both?
Well,
both good.
Are you kidding that,
that he barely made it out of that second round was getting his ass fucked up.
Fucked up.
But two out of 10.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So three is a a ten eight for Akiyama though.
Cause he was just fun out of it.
Yeah.
So they both 10 80 to each other.
They didn't need to give those ten eight rounds more.
They need to give those out sometimes and that's a bully beat downs.
Sean's getting dropped.
It has to be ten eight [inaudible].
You can't just like when when guys are getting hurt and they're stunned like
Calvin gas,
Neil Magni you,
you had that point.
I agree with you
around.
You got to give him ten eight that's not a tent.
That's not a regular ten nine round.
That's a different kind of round dude got clipped twice.
Drop twice.
Somebody tried to tell me the first ten nine row I had someone try to tell me
that the first round with gray Maynard versus Frankie Edgar,
was it ten nine round?
I would slap the fuck out of them.
I go three times.
This was a fucking professional judge.
We're having an argument about it.
Oh my God,
what are you talking about?
I go,
well,
that is the epitome of a ten eight round.
At least ten eight they should never be able to judge him again.
And he goes,
well,
no,
because the fight wasn't close to being stopped and shut the fuck up.
That was as close as a fight gets to be in stopped saying.
The guy was actually literally saying that to me and he said,
oh my God.
It was the most frustrating conversation I've ever had with somebody.
Well that hats cause I knew that this guy is professional.
What does that,
that's a Brazilian makes me sad.
Lama Wrangler
Juggle Dodging Capek Baras k Lama wrangling my momma is come on does that,
that's going to be hard man.
When you almost finished the guy in the second round but then you almost get
finished and the third and you walk away with a victory.
That's crazy.
Those kind of decisions are weird because I do go by the,
the idea that like I liked how pride did it where they judge the fight as a
whole.
But though I think and to of the round,
the end of the fights worth more because like if you're watching too,
this is the,
the,
the rationale behind it.
You're watching two kids fight in the school and the school yard and then it's
gone back and forth and back and forth.
But the end of the fight,
one dude gets on top of the other dude and full mountain punches him in the face
a bunch of times and then the teachers pull them off.
So at the end have Jimmy one,
that dude is on top dropping bombs on you.
He definitely won.
I don't care if you hit him 30 times before he took you down and he only landed
three punches while you were down.
If he was on top and he's punching you in the face when the teachers came,
you one legit,
right
elementary back.
I want you did in the first or second round.
Oh,
obviously it didn't mean anything because you're getting your ass beat at the
end is,
what about that knocked down in the first round.
That didn't mean shit.
Look,
look what's going on right now.
You're getting your ass kicked.
Yeah.
It say,
see it's going to be hard to judge like that because then people do like what
they do in Thailand where they wait for the bedding so they lay back in the
first couple of rounds.
You know,
you don't want to see people do that but also like it.
Let's take the Neil magni verse.
Kelvin fight.
When Neal had his back,
it was riding him for a long time.
Had his back for long ass time.
You know.
How's that cause that's a dominant position.
Yeah.
Mount.
It's a dominant position.
He wasn't doing any damage.
That's different.
He was threatening the choke that Renee could show with sue on the first two
rounds.
I'm not,
Dominic don't dominate to dominate,
but why isn't it though?
Kinda isn't it?
What do you mean?
Here's,
here's a,
here's if a guy is on your back for the whole round and he's trying to get that
choke and you're bat and it gets real close a couple of times,
it's in that kind of like a ten eight if it's close,
what I'm saying traveling wise,
that should be a ten eight the crowd's going nuts.
Then he escapes,
right?
That was close.
But if he just has someone's back for the entire round is
so striking,
just commercial sexy,
how much you can strike from the down in the mirror.
Look at this commercial.
What does this,
she's going is dominated what is going on in this commercial snotty.
She can't hit him,
but he's like on a massage chair,
closing his eyes like he's getting blown.
Well that's fucking hook.
It's him versus him.
He's a super star.
What is,
what are we looking at here?
Um,
so confused.
This is fight pass,
right?
So this is all the new inspiration,
dude.
He's a superstar out there.
I'm not mad at that door.
Like explore a haircut.
Oh my God.
It's a fucking an ad for a massage.
It's an ad for a massage chair.
I'll take it.
Have you ever seen that before though?
That confuses the shit out of me.
So what do you think right now with Aldo and McGregor?
That's a tough fucking call,
man.
If,
if you know,
I want Connor to win,
but do you?
I do.
I want Connor to win.
I really liked and I think it's better for the sport form to win.
I think moving forward as a,
as a,
you know,
you're the UFC man,
you want to win.
But Josie Aldo with again,
you know,
I take heat for this with the new testing.
I don't know how it's going to go down.
Oh my God.
How dare you.
You're just saying it.
Why are you saying that?
Cause he's Brazilian [inaudible]
I don't know man.
There's a lot of guys that we've seen fighting with now with the new testing.
It's a different story.
I'm not saying that he is on things.
I'm saying that's the x factor.
I'm not accusing him of shit when you're saying it could be a fact.
Okay,
that's all speculative.
Whatever,
whatever.
Nothing wrong with that.
But when you look at it as like as far as like past performances,
we look at it as far as like what their ability,
what they can do inside the octagon.
It should be an insane fight cause you look at,
although it hasn't lost in 10 years,
right,
it's been [inaudible] everybody's ass.
You watched like the,
the like the most spectacular victories that he's had.
Like the Cub Swanson Five Josie LQB pound for pound number one is,
yeah,
he's a fucking,
he's engaged.
He's a beast.
It do ask,
did you Jitsu Nat worldclass Jujitsu and some of the fastest leg kicks in the
fucking sport.
If you,
if you,
if you're going to bet on it.
I mean it's not bad money cause José's and underdog.
That's crazy.
That tries me.
I just,
I just don't understand how someone could call him and I'd have to see it.
You know the odds Jamie?
Yeah.
He's an underdog in Vegas.
You know?
What do you think the logic is that is just height and bedding type?
Well,
think about Rhonda Holly Grant Again.
We're all going to one 12 to one 12 to one.
It's all hype.
And I think a lot of people who make those odds,
they don't know the game inside and out.
But,
but you see Conor on every fuck gone or does smash people,
man.
I mean he really does.
He watched that Dustin [inaudible] fight.
You watch that fight with Dennis Seaver.
Jesus fucking Christ.
He smashes,
peep,
Josie.
All all those oils at a different hour cry from those two different animal.
They bolstered chins.
They both smashed.
So he's plus one 25.
So that's basically even in MMA.
Do you think that the,
uh,
so they're even right now,
damn,
look at,
look at that motherfucking fight card.
Chad is card.
It's the greatest fight card of all time.
Dude.
That's aggressive.
Mr Rogen,
you're not seeing the full car.
You've seen just bedding.
No.
Listen,
here's,
here's Yoel Romero versus jocker array.
So Jeremy Stevens versus Max Holloway.
Liotta him or not Leo them cheat or Luke Rockhold versus Chris Weidman for sure
that Conor McGregor versus Josie,
although that's amazing.
What's the top five?
You Saint Ben in Ufc 100 I don't know.
UFC 100 was Brock versus Frank Mir.
It was George Saint Pierre versus the Elvis.
Michael Bisping.
Dan Henderson,
and understand another barn burner on there too.
I'll say this is the best card,
the best card since then,
how about that?
Akiyama was on that bitch,
was he?
Yes,
and yeah.
John Jones on the undercard Akiyama versus Alan Belcher Belcher should've won.
Did yet.
Martin called Congress bond.
All right.
Here's um,
Ooh.
That's tough.
You don't not,
don't get me wrong.
I'm saying it's a great card.
It's definitely top three of all time.
There's one other big fight.
Oh,
Damien Maia versus fucking Gunnar Nelson.
That's our nuts on the main card.
That's on the main card.
So the,
here's the main card.
The main card is Max Holloway vs Jeremy Stevens.
Damien by a versus Gunnar Nelson.
Jose Aldo versus Conor McGregor.
Chris Weidman versus Luke Rockhold and shock IRA versus Yoel Romero.
I'm not mad at that at all.
It's hard to say.
That's not the best card.
Yeah.
That may know long fucking time like it does the very long,
it might be the best card since 100 but I agree.
It's debatable that we haven't had a card,
that stack that got about Damien Maia and Gunnar Nelson.
I forgot about that.
That's a fucking fight.
That's how good this card is.
You guys watch the ultimate fighter with Connor?
I've,
yeah,
I've seen it.
Yeah,
I forgot that you're riding favors on the undercard.
You know they have stacked it to make sure that if Aldo pulls out,
they've got,
they've got strategies,
they've got Uriah sitting on the undercard.
They've got Frankie Edgar and Chad Mendez fight in the day before.
I mean the whole thing is covered.
Like they've got the three top featherweight.
Even though they're doing that,
I should do that.
It shows a hour to pull out.
We're fucked.
I know Joe's a Connor is the only fun.
I love every fight.
It's great.
That's all fine and dandy.
Tell you what,
Frankie could go in there and make a nightmare that,
oh yeah,
Frankie,
he would make trouble.
Nightmare.
It's a bad idea.
He's a bad idea for almost everybody.
When you watch his fight with Cub Swanson,
that motherfucker swarms.
He's relentless.
He doesn't get tired.
He just has this most retarded pace.
Who's pace is so fast?
Footwork man and he's better.
He's better now than ever.
Frankie's like never backed off better now than ever.
I think those years out of the championship spotlight too.
I've just made his resolve even stronger.
Yeah.
That's going to meet some good fight that people were totally sleeping on that
Chad Mendez.
Frankie Edgar fight.
I thought I totally forgot about it in December that that whole,
there's a week he worked in all three.
No,
just one.
Yes.
Just for the big dog.
I can't do three in a row.
I wouldn't have a voice left.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
He's screaming.
The third night I be like,
oh,
and then the other main event is page verse rose.
Yeah.
Did you see what happened with Paige and the haircut thing?
I'm going to happen.
Kate page was supposed to like they were going to donate money if they get to a
certain amount just to find to be doing that.
She's waiting.
She got her and she's going to cut her hair up.
So instead she got a haircut.
Like her management team told her to cut her head off.
No,
she's got long hair,
still got trim and she just trimmed her.
It's just like normal shit.
That girl's not mad cause they don't talk about it.
She was like,
I'm just to get it.
It's like I'm going to wash myself for charity.
Well you thought you watched yourself every day.
Fuck you dude.
I'm brushing my teeth with Chitty.
Ah Man.
I'm not mad at it though.
Don't shave your head.
Yeah,
she is.
She came to fun.
She didn't.
That's a tough fight,
man.
So when stars go to fall,
yeah,
it's a good fight.
Rose's dangerous as fuck.
She is super finisher.
She's tough.
She's wild.
She throws up a lot of wild shit.
I'm not scared to be off her back.
No,
no.
Interesting fight.
Right pages.
Very scrappy to super scrappy.
That's a great fight.
Dominick waters and Dung Young Kim,
this should be a good fight,
man.
This is a good fight too.
Big Tall one seventies like mom,
man,
killer.
I don't know a Dominic waters.
Where does he train?
That's a good question.
Young Jamie,
please pull up the information on Mr. Waters.
Rufus maybe.
Do you see a behind him fighting at Albuquerque?
Some maybe.
Was that Greg Jackson's guys?
Yeah,
that's Isaac Valley.
So they're going to have a game plan for him.
Three
t t t t two submissions.
Hey Man.
Um,
did you notice that um,
Spike TV got rid of Bella tore or got rid of?
I'm not Beltre got rid of a glory.
No.
See what happened?
Yeah.
They got rid of it and ESPN picked it up.
No Way.
Yeah.
Is that better?
No,
not necessarily because I think it's like ESPN too.
I watched the glory fights when they were on ESPN two.
Pretty cool.
But you know,
there's so much shit on ESPN and I don't know how much they're going to like
connect with us via common ESPN intertwined at all.
I don't think so.
I think Viacom's releasing it.
I think glory,
like they had a licensing deal or something like that,
or a broadcast deal.
I think they're owned by different people,
you know?
I just think there's some,
you know,
there's,
there's some fans out there of kickboxing.
Just need to figure out a way to market it and put some money into it and get
people excited about it.
Yeah,
I fucking love it,
man.
I know they were trying to do Bella tour and glory and kind of intertwined some
of the,
the stars in there.
I guess it didn't work out as well as they wanted.
Yeah.
They had that one event where they had the ring right next to the cage,
which is pretty cool.
They tried to do a Japanese style,
you know,
that would have been cool to go to lives on Don Young.
Kim's back Donny on Kim's a nasty grappler.
Danny.
Yeah.
He's doing what Kim does,
but he's interesting too because a lot of,
a lot of judo in his style as well.
Yeah.
I was Daniel and Kim for a Tyrone Woodley when he fought them in China.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Okay.
We both fought on the same day.
Were you in China for that?
No,
I didn't go to China for that.
That was the one where he came charging at him,
right?
Yeah.
He tried to do it.
He's back fist or elbow and got murdered.
Clipped.
Yeah.
Mert just [inaudible] you can't rush it.
That dude.
Hell No.
Wait to explicitly not that first round.
The first round and now he's working with Duke.
Uriel is exactly that.
Well that was what I said.
Oh Shit.
Look at that.
Take down right aside.
Control what I said about uh oh shit fixed.
Tied that arm up with the quickness to mounted crucifix.
Just like that son,
Cade Dworkin and cage.
Oh,
ish.
Don't think so.
He's still near it though.
You got to push off that fucker.
Like you trying to base knocked down a tree.
Oh,
he's going to keep going for the elbow sun.
Mm.
Um,
well we're just talking about right arm out.
Killer be your card is stacked.
Yeah.
Passing cards.
I'm going to be there for that.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
I'm going to Boston.
You doing stand up at the two?
I would assume.
No,
no man,
I'm actually,
no,
I already had two things booked already had it Atlanta and um,
I'm in Atlanta and Tampa that weekend,
so I have two theaters that are already sold tickets for.
So then I'm going to fly into Boston on Sundays.
He,
dude,
my mom took your friend Joe.
My mom goes,
your friend Joe Rogan's and rolling stone.
Yes ma'am.
He's very famous,
very famous Mama.
It's been in a bunch of shit.
This is just the start.
Look at this damn fucking control to get that arm out.
Damn.
Can you stop it here because it's not really,
you know what I'm thinking is like fucking them up man.
He can't get his arm out.
It's weird how he can't get his arm right now.
Great control guys.
Obviously never spent a lot of time getting out of this,
but it seems like his strategy of getting out is not so good.
10 years ago,
some guy was owning people with this in the UFC like 10 years ago.
Like,
how do you stop it mounted?
Crucifix Roy Nelson who was before the,
before that for that Roy was big.
Uh hmm.
Someone was really,
this is like one of those things.
You have to stop the fight because he just can't defend himself.
You think?
Well that's these shots.
Well Roy is a heavyweight though.
That giant belly.
There's just a guy.
Yeah,
you're not getting at it.
But this is like very similar to stop the fire,
stop the fight we you get out of that mounted Crucifix Control that is to that
position.
Nascar levels and his levels super high.
You could tell right away.
It was so tight,
so tight.
Good balance.
But it was,
it seemed like waters had some space where his arm was.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
Like if it's first round too,
you're probably going to be trying to score him like he was all hips and trying
to explore this stuff.
People forget to work on.
He didn't know how to use his shoulders.
Right.
To copy shoulders up.
Exactly who,
just Roy have a fight.
Is there any announcement and what's next from boy,
didn't they announce a Barnett?
Rothwell somebody Photoshop to picture yet.
He did Barnett.
Rothwell's could that great.
I like that somebody photoshopped a picture of Roy Nelson with like Akiyama his
body.
Like that kind of body that is just shredded.
I don't know whose body they used to Photoshop it,
but it was another fighter.
But with him with a six pack yoked I was like,
oh my God,
that's what Roy would look like.
You fought one 85 like,
I mean it is what it would look like maybe.
I mean when you look at Roy,
how much weight do you think he could lose?
40 pounds.
Ten five nine?
Yeah,
about five 11 five 10 yeah.
40 50 pounds.
How much at that age?
I Dunno.
I mean,
let's forget about all that mean old people lose weight all the time.
Like I'll do it like a juice fast.
No age limited.
[inaudible] you can't like there's the picture.
That's the picture.
Oh it's Chelsea Manning's body.
Yeah,
look up there.
Look at that picture up there.
He imagines that shit was real.
Is the guy,
the guy in the back,
right?
Legit or is that a better shot to,
he's got his dick in his hand.
If you get lower on the picture of the ground,
the back shale was jacked.
It looks like Jelly on the phone.
Right?
Like
a hundred pounds.
You got to see this watch is fucking good though.
That's chill.
When he was about to fight,
Anderson was shredded dude look like that and was still knocking bitches out
like he does.
He would.
Okay.
That's,
yeah,
that's,
he would pay.
That's fucking tough.
Boy.
That's a big difference.
You'd be a huge star.
Yeah.
Well I wonder what kind of effect that would have on his performance,
his whole career he's been carrying around all that extra weight.
Yeah.
Like that's not outside the realm of possibility that he could actually make
that weight,
man.
What the,
I mean it is personality wise and he's choices wise,
but like as a physical specimen it's not,
you think he'd get down that without taking performance enhancing drugs and be
that shredded?
I don't know.
I go and say no.
Well,
I mean,
what is body fat,
right?
I mean,
you can lose body fat.
You don't have to be asked to lose muscle though too.
But if he looked like,
Dang,
you're writing,
probably we're going to lose.
I mean,
you're going to,
you're going to lose a little muscle,
a lot of fat,
and you get in great shape.
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
he just eat better.
If he dedicated himself to strength and conditioning and started running every
day and doing a bunch of shit.
It's the biggest thing by far.
If you ever fuck with a ketogenic diet,
if you're fuck with that.
I haven't,
man,
I did this thing with my DNA.
It's called simplified or yeah,
simplify genetics where you put your DNA and like a swab.
They send it to them and it gives a breakdown.
It's called simply fit where they do like a,
what kind of weights and cardio should be doing for your body,
what kind of diet you should be doing that best reacts with your,
you know,
your DNA.
And,
uh,
they also have one for concussions,
which was scary,
where they can tell from your DNA how proned to when you do get a concussion,
how bad it's going to be on a scale.
One to five.
Patrick big brown was a for real.
I was scared.
I wish they didn't send me that one.
I literally just got the results two days ago.
Oh my God.
I was like,
God damn it.
I don't need to know that.
That was a four and I'm fucked about you.
I got 10 years left guys.
If you're going to shoot some stem cells right into your brain,
just let him do it.
I'll be the Guinea pig right now,
but up the brain cavity,
let's do it.
Put a little thin hole there.
It'll show up.
I'm not mad at that syringe in there.
Pump right in the middle of your brain.
Boom.
Hopefully,
man,
you got to go to Germany for the legitimate or is that legit show?
They have it.
As far as the Santos here now here in La,
dude,
I had some shot into my shoulder in Vegas.
There were,
they use,
uh,
women's Placenta.
Women that have sincerity and sections.
They,
they get stem cells out of their placenta and they shoot it right into your
shoulder or whatever.
For me,
it was my shoulder,
dude.
I,
my shoulder was fucking with me for like a year.
I was real close to getting surgery.
I was like,
this is probably pretty bad.
I'm like,
it's,
it hurts after every work.
I'd have to put ice on it.
One stem cell shot,
boom,
done.
Now it's been four months.
It's getting better.
God Damn Nah,
that's not like it worked for a little while and then it backed off.
It's doing something different than all this platelet rich plasma and Regena key
and things along those lines,
which reduce inflammation,
promote healing,
and they're very beneficial.
But this is total next level mean women's Placenta.
What that set you back to 6 million?
What are we talking?
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's hard to get ahold of,
but I think a lot of women have Syrians.
I think it's pretty normal when they to save the fat.
Yeah.
Save the Hodor.
Could a type
cut on your belly.
No big thing.
They know the things.
Teach those things up good.
I think it happens all the time.
I don't think it's hard to get those,
um,
those,
those tissues.
And so they do it and oh,
by the way,
I got some of these bad ass pickles right here,
so I know you love those vehicles.
You'll look Grillo's pickles.
It's never too early for a pickle.
Um,
I ate four of them before you guys got hit.
Oh Damn.
That's what you had for breakfast.
No,
I haven't had breakfast.
Yeah,
I mean it's too early.
I'm not even going to pretend when you make those posts at night,
if you're fucking elk meat and Moose,
I have fucking chipotle a or something makes you feel bad about myself.
I like to cook it when everyone's asleep.
I know.
It looks so nice when you have eggs and shit.
It makes me so angry.
And they did.
Didn't you do cranberry sauce that I make today?
Today I made my own home.
Homemade cranberry sauce.
I was fucking,
it's so easy to do.
Really?
Yeah,
it's super easy.
And cranberry sauce.
It's like a two to one water and sugar like uh,
like uh,
uh,
I think I have uh,
yeah,
I think it was like four cups of coffee.
Two cups of cranberries,
one cup of sugar and one couple.
It's all sugar.
You're not going to be like sex bitch.
How do you the air here?
This is crazy weird man bro.
This is madness.
He was on TV and he's right here.
There's Rogan's fucking cram as my cranberry sauce.
Look at that.
I made that shit.
Do something.
I have to stop following you at night.
I'm like fuck it.
I just,
I just send that though.
Postmates go pick me up some food to it.
If we were neighbors I would have you come over and eat some.
Hell I'd be over in the middle of the night.
Oh,
you would love it too,
by the way.
I got this water to commercial freezers here cause I,
I shot so much elk this year.
I got some elk for you.
Oh,
I'm not mass.
I have some right here.
Be Dope Man.
I got something for you too,
Eddie.
But I don't know if you're going to eat it.
He won't eat it.
Why not anyone?
Just like you have to heal each chipolte leg or my big push you do.
You know Joe Polian and that equalize shit going on right now.
If you liked your pull a fucking go there.
It's like the Wa dead.
No one's there because equalize stuff.
Oh,
cause they had an Ecolab ecolab everywhere.
Every,
all in,
in,
uh,
it's like all over the shutting them down and shit.
Really?
There's that many of them that are having problems really trouble.
Jamie's nodding.
Whoa.
That's not good.
I mean there used to be a line out the door.
I want that the other day.
There's no,
we know what it is.
Scared.
Don't know what it is.
They don't know what started that first couple of stores that found,
then they stripped him clean,
clean them on it.
Then they couldn't find the trace trickling over.
Right.
In Ohio it's been like seven or eight states.
Yeah.
I get equal.
I every time I eat there,
every time he did,
you love it.
We'll get that fucking card son.
Dude.
Sousa.
Romero who,
what's your love that
fight?
Yeah.
I just wished that you bro.
Yo Al was younger.
You know,
I feel like we're getting this super athlete,
one of the greatest wrestlers of all time and we're getting them deep into his
career.
He's got a guy beat Cael Sanderson twice,
you know,
I mean Yo Romero was a monster athletes.
Super.
We're getting him at like 36 when they have the most stringent testing.
It's so unfortunate.
It's like giving a Sammy Sosa now I'm good.
You know,
it's like I did this um,
interview medic beast.
Yeah.
Oh he is for sure.
Goddamn we,
that combination that's front kicks the body in that left hand columns.
That mother Fucker,
Dude.
Motherfucker,
you said motherfuckers fucked at one 45.
He's a beast,
dude.
He's a beat Weidman.
Rock guys know that rot ride man stopped drinking and now he weighs 190 pounds.
Damn.
He's waking up in the morning at one 93 said he said he's a,
he's essentially a welter weight.
Stop Drinking,
stop drinking booze.
Started eating really healthy and he's coming into this fight really lean.
I think he maybe anticipates like a serious pace or maybe it could.
It's a weight cut.
Yeah.
With the IB,
I think this is the hardest fight to call from me.
I think it's the greatest fight in middleweight history.
It's a great fight.
You know,
the only thing that it would be the greatest all time fight if Rockhold didn't
have that fight Vietor Ah,
c'mon.
Towards an asterick.
It is.
But when v tour we'll kicked him in the head and stopped him in the first round
like that.
It did sort of change the perception of Roscoe.
What you're saying.
I just liked that school rating.
Yeah.
Like they're,
both of them are ever going to be this good again,
I don't think,
I think the trick is so strong to TRT years of veto or are so it's such just
the,
I'm so torn more than on any other fighter because I think like Trt v Tor is
probably like one of my all time favorite fighters.
It might be my favorite fighter.
Just like right.
Taking guys eyes off straight up.
He's like one of my all time favorite.
This Jon Jones beat him sauce out of his mind.
That's,
that's fucked up.
I like Anna drawl veto when he was 19 when he had the traps that did you guys
hear and no technique.
50 leads to heavy hand shit.
He was like a lion who's built like a lion.
Is Muscle started at the top of his head.
His went straight down like ski ramps.
Did you see that Jon Jones interview?
Yeah.
Well I think Jon Jones has a really good point that someone in the athletic
commission,
Whoever's responsible,
didn't tell him that Victoria had tested positive or that he had tested with
elevated test levels.
They didn't tell him and they let him fight.
You fight.
If that's true.
He's got a legit shoe.
And he goes,
oh no,
I have three years to press charges.
He goes,
don't worry.
I'm not forgetting.
Yeah,
well he shouldn't.
Whoever did that,
whether it's the athletic commission,
whatever,
who,
who's responsible at that point in time?
Who's responsible?
I think it's a combo of things.
Is it the UFC and the athletic commission?
I think so.
But how your people or you'd have to be,
you know,
ridiculous.
If you don't think of the UFC brass knew what Vittorio was doing.
Well,
wasn't this a time where Vito took the fight on short notice because Chael
Sonnen was that the same fight knows different funds,
different a fight.
I'm mean,
I'm confused.
He's that fight actually didn't happen.
Yes,
and people gave John a lot of shit,
which by the way,
in any other sport,
in any other sport.
Yeah,
it was Dan Harrington.
In any other sport,
that would be a ridiculous thing to ask.
Dick does to ask Miguel Cotto last minute to not fight Canelo Alvarez,
but to fight Floyd Mayweather.
Everybody was like,
what the fuck are you talking love John's explanation.
It's like,
no man,
I took,
there's so many years of training to get to world Chaim ship level and then you
want me to do this,
and he goes and then you're making me look like an asshole.
That's not cool,
man.
Boy,
he gave chill fucking beating after that because all the shit and shale was
talking.
Oh my God.
He gave him such a beating that he broke his own toe pushing off the mat while
he's beating the fuck out of him.
Dude hop,
I'm up in the interview.
He's like,
yeah,
you know,
now I'm just going to start taking this serious and start training.
Oh God,
fuck no.
Good luck to you buddy.
You watching all this power lifting going,
Ooh,
don't get hurt.
You know like you really,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
He's training like professional athlete now.
True.
What block?
Dead lifting.
400 squat and 500 and he's dead lifting 600
is he think he's going for his,
his Max on Monday.
How much does he might run it?
Not a fan boy at camp.
I'm a fan boy,
but next Monday the big 600 pound dead lift is scheduled for Monday,
but he's going to watch his weight if you stay until
two 28 shredders to 2028 so he's lost body fat.
Yes.
Shred that factor in that extra muscle and his endurance.
I mean it's going to,
it's more of a requirement,
right?
I,
I think it's going to help him cause he's,
he's going to be stronger.
He's never been a knockout guy,
but we see maybe a little more knockouts and he's also not being the guy who,
who,
who's trained outside camp now he's training.
So I think his body's going to adapt to it.
I think he's built for it man.
Wow Man.
He talked about going to heavyweight too.
I was going to say,
or he does because he said it's just a matter of time.
The weight cut fuck.
Especially with the IVS and whatnot because I know he was talking about it for a
while.
Going to heavyweight and he probably cuts a lot and that's probably a pretty
hard cut.
So big,
big fight,
right,
is Weidman.
If Weidman can beat Rockhold,
which is obviously a big,
if that's a big fine.
Rodman Weidman beats Rockhold and Jon Jones and Weidman hookup in Madison Square
Garden.
Good fucking googly Mooglie
look at the difference.
There's a John Jones a before and after picture.
We're looking at all over the Internet of him,
dude,
where he's like a add a shape in between camps.
For one fight and like I think that was 2013 and then 2015 he's on the right and
just looks like the hulk dude.
He said when he was fighting Alexander and he was like,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
the first time I was tired of the fight cause I really didn't train what the
fuck.
And this dude's still goes into the octagon confident.
It's insane how talented that dude is.
He's super talented,
that's for sure.
Bruton Forman.
Um,
I'm interested to see what's going to happen with this.
with this v tour thing.
If they really did know that he had elevated test level,
I'm sure nothing to come out until after he's done fighting.
Because if,
you know,
when you look at the fight,
Jon got continent deep arm bar in that.
Yes.
And what if his arm broke?
But what if it broke and what if that like fucked up his career.
And then we found out that Victoria had elevated test levels of a law suit on
your motherfucking hands.
It's all very crazy,
man.
It's a very strange time because I feel like,
you know there's,
they're saving the blood and they're saving the urine for years.
I think like eight years and how many people are d they're getting by on the
sneak tip with some,
some shit that they haven't figured out that what are you going to do with that,
say blood and urine like eight years from now?
The Shit on legends?
Yes.
That's fucked up,
man.
That's what they did kind of fucked up.
That's gotta be fucked up.
Oh,
you're out of the sport.
You're a commentator now.
You got wife and kids.
Check this out.
Here's this.
We're just going to shit on everything you've ever done.
I mean,
there's probably going to be a lot of extra blood that's unnecessary then.
Right?
Because how many fighters are probably going to get that in seven years from now
then we'll do well fun.
What's going to happen is when sophisticated testing,
when when improves,
when it gets better and better,
then they're going to go,
oh well now like they,
you didn't use to be able to test for EPO.
They didn't used to be able to test for h g h is a real recent one,
right?
Yeah.
And now apparently there's a,
there's a new version of artificial testosterone that they're getting from
animals.
They're not getting it from yams anymore.
They were getting it somehow or another from wild yams.
I'll let him know I'm too fucking stupid for this.
But now apparently they're figuring out how to extract it from animals and when
they give it to people,
it doesn't show up.
It's like the carbon isotope test doesn't show up.
But wouldn't your,
your levels would still be elevated?
Yeah,
you'd have high levels,
but they would be,
even though they were high,
they would still be human level.
Oh,
Gotcha.
Like when they do that carbon isotope test,
apparently they test it and they can tell.
They're like,
oh motherfucker,
you got yams running through your veins.
Well,
my thing is I,
so,
so you're gonna store all this blood and shit like that for eight years.
You could you tell me a guy tested positive at eight years from now.
I'm like,
what dude?
Who's been watching this shit?
[inaudible] who's been dealing with it.
Yeah.
Has it been,
they have,
they have a facility where they have like a chain of custody and they have 24
hour security cameras and uh,
you know all that good shit,
dude.
I don't,
I dunno.
I don't trust it and make it shut up.
[inaudible]
qualities.
The same people.
They do the Olympics or that's what Wata is,
you know,
that's what the u s USAID Da Dude,
we have the strictest testing of any sport,
any sport by far.
But you know,
intense.
You know what?
Hey,
maybe focus on the fight.
Gets the testing.
At least let the fights have love the UFC.
At least you're talking about Reebok Brown area.
Well,
I mean,
let's put a little money into that.
Huh?
Fuck the testing.
They spelled most of the people's names,
right.
Give them some breaks.
You're right,
man.
They put on it for Connor shirt and they put the u s flag on it.
Conor McGregor.
Yeah,
they did.
Yes,
they did know.
They did real Fantic picture on it cause he,
I think he's from Ireland but the Conor Mcgregor Jersey flagging this,
this can't be right.
Is it?
Isn't it weird that all this shit that Reeboks taken on their designs and they
still haven't changed anything by now,
they would've changed the goddamn design.
That's their problem.
Huge problem.
But if you say,
if you change the design,
you have to admit that it sucked.
What's wrong with that?
Oh our bad.
We didn't realize this is going to suck balls so bad.
You just got to get used to this.
No you can't.
You got to get used to that fighting with white shorts on so that as soon as
her,
any blood or their junk gets outlined,
their ass looks like they shit themselves cause they just running around on the
on the ground.
Dude.
Why not just be like,
oh my bad,
my bad.
We fucked up.
Here's the new one that we've been working on.
We spent way more time on this.
I think they said it's a,
it's a two year process.
Like every two years they're going to change the style,
evolve the,
the uniform.
You know what I think they should eliminate,
they should eliminate shorts.
Make everybody fight with tights on.
I get annoyed when dudes grabbed shorts.
I'm like,
why do they have something to grab like a,
you know,
don't grab a shorts.
Don't grab a short.
It's like why is that an option?
Why is it an option to grab when the tights though?
Cause they don't like the way they look.
Yeah.
They don't want anybody to see there that you talked to.
The guy was tired.
So I like to let my shit out.
Hey everyone.
Ha Ha.
Don't act like you're not a bro.
Benson Henderson love this dude.
Yeah,
I liked him at one 72 they what's interesting,
a lot of people don't know this.
This is his last fight on the UFC contract.
This is his last fight.
The last fight.
You know,
if someone like him went over to Bellator,
that would make a big noise.
You know,
they've got Phil Davis,
which I think made some good noise,
you know.
But if they can get like,
can you imagine?
Imagine.
What about Jon Jones contract goes up.
He's a judge Jones bales and goes over to Bella tour.
[inaudible] that what if Ron was did lord?
Oh good Lord.
Rhonda did.
If that was the game plan,
Dana White's head would explode.
It would be like that movie scanners.
You might take a little big and make your brain explode.
The staring at you that Jake Dan to be at a press conference and boom,
and then Conor McGregor Neves leaves the next day
his brain pulls back together and then explodes again.
Paul,
if Viacom really wanted like they have so much money,
if they really wanted to sink in and just blow like a couple hundred million
bucks and go look,
which is fucking take over this bitch,
it's make it spike TV,
MMA.
That'd be how many people do you think they could do that too?
How many people would take the chance?
You'd have to give him so much money that they don't ever have to fight again.
I agree that that,
okay.
Yeah.
You'd have to give each guy like Benson Anderson,
you have to give them like 3 million bucks.
It's just not the same.
Like you're just,
even if you have all that money,
you're just never going to be the same superstar over there.
It's just,
it doesn't last.
Everybody jumped ship.
It would have to be like almost like a mass exodus.
Well then belt or it needs to do a lot of things different,
but you have to stop calling it Bella tour for rails.
Come on man,
and that Shitty logo.
We've got to figure this out.
Benson,
that was up in the air like when it got taken over by Scott Koger.
They weren't sure if they were going to keep up.
Bellator.
MMA should have asked bigger town straight advice.
No matter what you call it does not.
It kind of does marketing wise,
knowing that does marketing does bands,
you can call,
you don't call this UFC anymore.
Call a Kissy Kissy POW.
Pow.
Yeah.
Let me know how that goes.
Yeah,
exact time for the Kissy kissy power world championships,
brandings,
everything.
My man name who didn't even heard of a Bella tour before and yet to grow hootie
and the blowfish.
You know what I mean?
It doesn't matter.
Tompkins.
It doesn't matter where they know.
Where is it?
Where are they now?
What does,
who do you know?
Who needs the fucking country singer?
Cause that shit don't work out.
And he changed his name.
His name is Daryl now.
His name is Daryl.
He loves country music is a huge country star.
Real.
His name's Darryl.
Wow.
One hit right?
That one,
that one album,
I think pretty much.
They have a lot of countries.
They were gigantic with slightly overweight white girls.
It's true.
That puts where they did their best damage.
They're good songs,
man.
Who did the blowfish?
We're good.
And I'll tell you what,
man,
that Guy Darrius Rucker,
right?
That's serious.
That's right.
He's great fucking Royce Ma'am.
And the country music people,
they needed a guy like him.
Like see,
we're diverse shit.
You mean a black guy?
Joe,
shut the fuck up.
You said that guy like a pop singer.
He's
fucking Hendrix of country.
Yo look out yoked.
Benson looks hooks yoked.
Who looks good man at one 70 and not having to destroy his body anymore.
Five nine is that short for one 70 not doing Johnny Hendricks.
I think it's five.
Eight.
How about Johnny changing camps?
He's leaving team because team take them.
That's it.
All this money into him,
right?
Like built them up.
I don't know how that works.
How's cause it was a bunch of different versions of how I got 50 50 I deal.
I'm pretty sure you like they gave him a salary and then they would get 50% of
his salary that they took care of like a house to live in basically.
Well who knows at this point you become a champion.
Champion.
50 fuck.
You might have bought a house.
This is a good fight,
man.
Great fight.
This is a real your dogs.
One of my favorite fighters to watch.
He's very crafty.
He was one of those old school,
uh,
brawlers of Kimbo brawlers with Kim and Miami man.
I've seen him.
I like watching him fight man.
He's very smart.
He's phenomenal striker and I think at one 70,
again,
he's a guy who doesn't have to hurt his body to fucking make that weight.
I agree.
We're going to see that more and more like Robert Whitaker when he fought Uriah
hall.
Like that's three in a row.
Five true.
A lot of people were saying he's too small for 85,
three in a row at 85 looks awesome.
Yeah.
Really good power of striking mosfet all slick,
super slick man and good transitions between striking grappling.
But Benson is such a good grappler.
I'm interested to see like where this takes place.
Ben's and spent,
you know,
bent and uh,
outside can't spends all his time in the GE does it.
Yes.
Interesting.
John Crouched from that old school Gracie lineage to John Crouch.
My first Jujitsu coach.
Really?
I held the door open for Ben.
He wasn't,
he was just getting ready to fight,
pursuing it and uh,
you know,
walked in.
We trained together then this is no light.
Next time I saw him we were both in UFC signing posters.
Wow.
Just a good dude,
man.
Great Guy.
Settle legs on him.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah,
he's like keeping it in kicking distance.
Ooh,
Nice.
Right hand Benson's keeping it in his distance and Mosfet I was trying to close
it out.
Oh,
nice shot by Mosfet.
I'll write to the body and the right hand.
I'd give the striking edge has Woodall but doesn't look like you so far.
Well,
so far Benson was keeping him on the outside,
but that combination,
that right kick to the body and right hand that had some fucking steam on it.
Mosfet I was throwing heat,
man.
He's throwing hard shots so it bends.
Try knock his ass out too though.
I've got switch kick too.
Yes.
Mosfet also had some knee problems.
So many guys have knee problems,
ma'am.
So common dude.
And these are nothing to fuck with either.
You know,
a lot of times it ruins NFL guys careers.
Call Him.
He ain't got his knee shot up with the stem cells.
Boom says he's all good,
right?
Yeah,
no surgery.
He was ready to get surgery was thinking about it.
That stem cells.
It's motherfucker dude.
And this is just the beginning.
Oh,
vice counter.
Right.
Great.
Chatbook yeah.
Dude.
How bout,
uh,
what if they did DC John Jones,
mass square guy.
Good fucking Lord.
That's a great fight.
Is it a great fight?
I love that.
Yeah.
Because I think the DC gets a second chance.
DC,
uh,
more,
more experienced and I'm not gonna fall for the emotional roller coaster ride
that he got in with John.
Uh,
it's probably going to stay calm and also doesn't,
uh,
you know,
his knees not as fucked up,
but did I learn these young with Denny's dealing with a focus?
John,
who's like not doing coke three weeks out and already been already beat up too.
You know,
already beat him.
That's fine.
It has to happen.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's happening.
It's happening.
For sure.
That's the next fight for dcs,
John.
That's a guaranteed to happen.
I'm just saying at Madison Square Garden,
will it happen?
Give it to John John's right away.
Dot.
Madison Square Garden is not,
it's not definitely,
you know,
it's definitely not definite.
I think they have to jump through a lot of hoops before April and making it
difficult and it's our,
oh shit.
Oh,
he caught him with the right hand and that was right when Mazda,
when I was going with that right kick to the body again too.
Okay.
Madison Square Garden.
UFC would be fucking insane.
Insane.
It would be.
And so you've got to stack that card like this December card.
You got to just bring the no past and no,
no,
they're still,
it's crazy that it's not.
Oh Nice.
Left to the body.
You hurt him with that left hand or the body mosfet all sneaky.
How's think that's,
I can tell an elite striker,
when you see guys go to the body,
that was perfect placement to phenomenal
Muscovy doll.
Oh,
acts crazy.
There's that.
He keeps landing that right.
Cute.
Cause we'll mix it up in his Jujitsu is sneaky on the ground,
man.
Who leg kick that lesson for him?
God Damn,
he's opening up.
Yeah.
That was like five in a row.
Rolling
pins.
Heroes gets in his fucking face.
He's always touching it.
You said who was he fighting?
He was fighting.
Was it Frankie when you'd pull his hair back?
Frank would jump on her mirror that.
Yeah.
Pounce and they were timing it after the first fight.
It was a nice leg kick.
I wonder if want to notice how much he touches his hair really should cut it
off.
He's a corn row it.
Well,
something it just gets so in the way.
Whatever you do,
stop doing what you're doing.
Yeah.
There's one more thing that he doesn't have to think about.
I agree.
That's what rose cut her hair.
Right?
Should I send the way?
Fuck this noise.
Yeah.
I mean it's crazy.
That page wouldn't do it.
Burrows is equally pretty.
She's beautiful bro.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Rosa super.
She actually,
she actually pulls the shaved head off.
She has some,
oh,
he nailed them on that knee going down now son.
Look,
get that.
Maybe itch.
Don't think so.
Damn takedown defense mom.
Look at them.
Super Confident.
He's laughing.
Dude.
Do Ben ones.
This one is second big win at one 70 I mean he's right up there,
man.
You got to give a guy like that.
This is five rounds to men.
We just watch round one.
And who do you think won that round?
If you had a judge,
the doll mosfet [inaudible]
if that's a ten nine round,
how is Frankie Edgar versus gray Maynard?
You guys should be put down.
I should be putting like a horse with three broken legs.
What happened?
Right?
Get Frankie Edgar got cracked in the first round where he was down multiple
times.
We'll completely wobbled,
looked like it was out to,
it's a ten eight round of five Evers and I'd be surprised if you told me ten six
Oh yeah,
I'm cool with that.
Ten nine I'm like fuck.
He tried to tell him it was ten nine because the end of the round Frankie had
recovered.
I'm like,
you just need to shut your mouth dude.
If we were in a restaurant and he told him that I'd piss in his mouth,
I would have stood on the table and piss right on his mouth.
Wow.
Yeah.
You're at rest bro.
[inaudible] your yard
like a lion round dose.
How about Ben Henderson had a big fucking Joe rigs in his corner.
Old School.
Well diesel's been trained with them,
right?
Yeah.
He was in a Riggs.
Is Corner against me.
Is Rigs in the UFC?
Um,
is he still in the UFC is lost his last fight?
No,
he lost the Cote de Right?
Yeah.
Was that the last fight?
I think so.
He'd won one before that.
Right?
Who did he fight?
Ron Stallings.
Dan,
you know Patrick?
Oh,
taste for steam all cutie.
I mean,
people take that dude,
you know this?
Yes.
Quebec.
You're not white.
You're not,
might hates mosfet dolls landing that right.
Kick to the body a lot.
That's a good kick for him,
man.
Dude.
His striking,
I mean,
top
notch,
man,
that makes very crisp.
I'm not mad at it's fade either on his,
yeah.
I'm also not matter.
It's takedown defense.
That was really impressive.
That was impressive.
Banking gets you down.
He's like roommates with Colby Covington.
Fuck Dude.
You have that guys like your,
your favorite training partner and you're going to get good at wrestling,
man.
Well they have monsters that att right.
Wrestlers.
I mean,
it's just full of that,
but definitely I am,
man.
He brought his game up.
Gym kicked to the body.
Have you seen the new one?
Dan Lambert has opened up a new giant.
A t.
T.
Have you been in coconut creek?
I haven't been to the new one.
Um,
oh,
shut up buildup.
Is he her?
He did.
He's hurt leg.
Someone bleeding.
Something happened.
Is that from old?
That Akiyama was button.
Oh,
his daughter says nasty brownies.
Nope.
Maslow dolls.
Darcy's are fucking nasty man.
He got a Cisa with a dark,
we were talking,
we missed the Ya know,
yet Cisa with the AH,
Jeez.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit.
Oh Man.
They're throwing down.
Damn Mazda doll.
I love his movement,
man.
His head mom,
he's always moving.
He's sharp.
Very sharp.
I never root against Bendo though.
What did I wonder if there's any benefit of having all that hair for sure not.
I was thinking the comfort factor.
You guys were saying,
Oh he needs to shave it.
But like if you're in the fight and you like,
he keeps a toothpick and if you get used to just moving your hair back,
maybe that's Kinda like your reset in your head.
You.
It's like,
okay,
I'm just chilling out,
get in my breath back and then you're coming with the combos.
Who knows,
man.
On a psychological level it could be their true.
He's so,
you'd be like a comfort zone thing.
Guys are timing it.
Like Frankie Edgar timed it when he would touch his here.
Frankie would fucking come at on the toothpick thing is so insane.
The fact that he's fought world championship fights with a toothpick stuck
inside of his mouth.
That is weird.
It's just like a comfort thing.
Some people use their breathing as a comfort thing to relax their breath and be
like,
all right,
I'm good,
I'm safe.
I go back to my breathing and he does a toothpaste.
Some people think that chilling,
like I had an old Japanese surfer stoner,
a student named Yoshi and he still rolling.
Did you get to and chew gum?
He said that that that when you're chilling it keeps you sharper.
Yeah.
A lot of people believe that.
A lot of people would play pool that chew gum.
Really?
Yeah.
Another thing I've heard is that when you chew gum before something,
it's good because your body relaxes because it says,
well,
we can't be in danger.
This mother fucker wouldn't be eating day.
Um,
yeah,
that might choose grow side,
wrong size
or maybe maybe to the fullest.
There's some more bro.
Science.
She guy's full of shit.
You're sharper because your body is going.
This motherfucker's eat and he's vulnerable.
You better keep those senses on point because Ryan,
I get attacked by some a wolverine and makes sense for sure,
bro.
Science,
but
science to a new place.
I'm going to go with that.
Oh Man.
This is a good fight,
man.
Ooh,
Nice Jab.
Ooh.
I'd love to see what kind of contract belt or offers.
Ben,
after this,
do you think they're going to offer him 110% what if it loses the,
Oh shit.
He's still from teen.
Oh No,
no more
interesting.
Yeah.
I wonder why you abandoned that,
but he's going back to it.
Maybe he likes it on the right side better.
Oh Shit.
Maybe he likes it on the right side better and all he lost transitions.
Nasty.
Oh Man.
It was a bad idea.
I hate this.
[inaudible] he's lifting him up and Neiman the Fed.
Talk about the veteran.
Talk about a veteran fucking move.
That's a great move.
Hell yeah.
That's a good move because that position is terrible.
The touch can't grouch,
man.
People touch the ground.
You can't name in the head if you don't know what we're talking about.
Oh Shit.
He fucked his face hands,
son.
Mosfet all face is a mess now from those knees.
That was some slick shit.
That was pretty slick.
Hell yeah.
That was dope.
I just think that that relying on that,
it's crazy.
It is crazy.
And the the,
that gray area where it's the transits,
you're touching you again in the face and they stop it.
Stupid.
I liked what herb dean does.
Herb deem someone is doing that and they get nailed.
He goes,
you're playing the game and you tell him don't play it again.
Herb's the best Combo,
man.
God Damn.
What the fuck on round.
Yeah.
Great.
Main event too.
Dude.
Why am I the one was pissed.
No one drink as much coffee as conditioned for this shit.
For Real.
My body's gotten so used to it.
I go three rounds.
I'll be drinking coffee three hours and then he'd just do you just go real a
piss it when you get out of this ridiculous back.
Where's all that piss coming from?
Raging River after a storm.
Ah,
dude.
Hell,
how come they don't have the roundup there?
That's all they do.
The through how they do this weird dashes on the bottom here.
Bull and they're white and it blends in with the ring.
Yeah.
That's a little odd,
isn't it?
How about the number three you fucks about round to,
how about the cow up?
The sponsors in Korea.
How about the sponsor?
The main sponsor was that massage chair.
It's in the middle.
Okay.
Is one of the other ones.
Whatever.
Okay.
Is See out there.
That's the shit.
It's like water
soccer.
Rub a water shirt.
Interesting.
This is an interesting fight,
right?
Yeah.
Really good fight man.
Back and forth.
Hard to hard to judge.
I like a fight.
Like this being five rounds to fuck.
Yes.
Cause it's going to get more clear as these rounds go on.
Who the judges are from,
where did they fly him in?
Are we talking about some Korean judges?
That's a good question.
Since sexy.
I'm a lost,
I got assume they're not Korean because Korea is like notoriously bad for or
known for bad decisions because of the Roy Jones Jr fight.
Remember when Roy Jones Jr fought in Seoul,
South Korea in the finals of the Olympics,
lit that dude up like a fucking Christmas tree in Times Square and they gave it
to the Korean.
That's ridiculous.
I remember that.
And then the Olympic Committee,
they got in trouble and there's all this like allegations of bribery.
Oh it was so obviously dirty.
It was so obviously dirty.
You go and watch that fight.
Roy Jones jr Roy Jones Jr and he still lost decision.
It was awful.
I've seen it in uh,
in taekwondo tournaments too.
Heavy favoritism.
At least they used to.
In boxing,
it's the worst in boxing.
You never know what the fuck's it.
[inaudible] in the Bradley out fight.
We just saw it tonight is Vladimir Klitschko and Tyson fury.
That's a fucking fight.
Fight.
Anything outside fight.
Helia fury.
He's undefeated and not to mention this,
the first fight or that Klitschkos face that's bigger than yeah,
taller.
Those almost knocking dudes out.
Yeah.
This is VR and has a really high work rate.
Yes,
a dude.
So I think Klitschkos going to beat fury.
The fucking fight is this monster,
this dime piece of a man in England named Joshua.
He's it.
He won gold in the Olympics.
You got to see this dude.
Who is he?
He's he.
I think he's six,
seven light on his feet.
Athletic knocking dudes out on defeated.
I'm really Helen healthy.
This is the next motherfucker.
What's his name?
Joshua.
We'll bring him up.
He's,
I forget his first name.
He's a heavyweight from ohs.
Last name.
What is it?
James.
Joshua.
Anthony.
And where's he from?
England.
Wait,
do you see this dude?
He's,
he has charisma.
He's marketable.
He's knocking dudes out.
He's athletic is fucked.
Brendan Schaub moving into sports management to tell you why.
What do you see this dude though?
I'm up,
Jamie.
I want to say,
oh my God.
That's a real dude.
One goal.
Put a super heavyweight.
Pull up a video of him boxing.
Let's show a video of him box.
He's athletic,
man.
What's his name?
Anthony.
Joshua.
How many fights is you have so far wins a super heavyweight boxing.
Let's not.
Oh Shit.
Look at them and bought and the Olympics.
Give us a highlight on my son's.
Let's get this hype train started.
Get those guns though.
Serious Jab.
Ooh,
good fundamentals.
See if you can find like a professional by day.
Y'All highlights so Mazda dog or kicked in the balls.
Desert
timing sells.
Paul kicking festival.
That looks like a,
a Olympic boxing,
bro.
See if you can find one.
That's a professional fight.
He's doing MMA now.
No,
no,
no.
He's,
he's he's box.
I don't think he's the next guy to compete with those guys.
Okay.
Here's him.
Oh Jesus.
For how big he is,
man.
We got all those people.
That crowd is crunk is fuck,
I
had such a great statement.
Crowd is looking at that dude's body.
He should deter.
I did.
Did,
did,
did the did interesting.
Well that's what they've been waiting for,
right?
Oh my God,
look at,
he works out like a pro athlete too,
for sure.
Don't show us him on the quad machine.
Boy highlight reel.
Nah.
So who's winning this fight?
We need to pay attention.
The last wine Joshua came in and this round,
I'm not sure.
So right now you believe one on one?
Yeah,
though we did drop him in the first round.
I would imagine he finished strong mosfet all in the first round.
So they would give it to him.
So maybe one,
two rounds to Mosfet all of that.
That's what I would say with
Henderson,
wasn't it?
Yes.
That's why B two to one.
So I'd give that probably the first round of Mazda doll third round.
Uh,
even though it got knocked down,
he didn't finish that strong.
I mean,
he beat him.
Right?
That's why I don't know.
But it would be more realistically,
we shouldn't score when we're not even paying any attention.
This is broken.
This is Bros for pro score.
Yeah,
this is Bruce going out.
It's fine.
Watched five minutes of this fight in its entirety once I've seen about a minute
20 of this and I do like the way mosfet all moves man.
Ooh.
Is that kick to the body?
His control and distance are really good too.
And knowing when to hit that switch kick when he's really tall.
Yeah man.
It's a festival.
It's a dick.
Good time for a piss break though.
Jesus Christ Benson,
he's still sitting on is on the bottom going to say.
I was going to say that was pretty interesting.
And they gave him a stool to sit in while they waited for is the end of the
fight.
Oh,
the round.
But look at this.
Oh that was totally accidental.
They clashed knees and it went right into the g
Oh time man.
Okay.
That was it.
Yeah,
time in.
But it was one second.
Okay,
so then they bring the corners.
So was it the end of the fight or end of the round?
It's just,
it's interesting that more people don't wear those compression shorts like
diamond m and makeups,
which is amazing.
They're amazing.
Amazing.
But it's very rare like fighters,
a lot of them don't even know about them.
A lot of guys like the Tie Steel Cup.
Do you like to Tie Steel Cup?
Uh,
no.
No,
it was 50 50.
Another thing you always got to worry about when you're dealing with those is if
by any way it does pincher or naked,
you're still getting,
see now you're getting that smashed by the cup itself.
Yeah,
but a couple of balls.
I do.
They can.
The edge of your balls can get caught with a cop on a guy like Gilbert.
I'm also office.
So awful.
So what,
what uh,
kind of cup prevents that is there or it doesn't matter.
The diamond club,
honestly,
he hooked me up when I went to Chicago.
He gave me one and I was the first time I ever used it.
And it do your balls get pinched?
No,
I love it.
It feels phenomenal.
Diamond Cup ever made.
Okay,
so what do they do differently that that prevents the ball's being crazy setup
with the compression shorts and all these straps and everything and then the cup
itself as like soft on the outside on the edges where it like connects to your
leg but then hard everywhere else and it's regular cup.
That's a real good junior.
All American football.
A little bit of friend steal it.
Never use one of those diamond ones.
Never.
I got one for you.
I never use comp.
Do you want one?
Oh,
you don't want your at work?
I don't either.
So okay.
I like my balls hanging Dick swingers.
Me Too.
Goddamn Dr. Rough my shit up.
Like a callous telling you man.
This diamond ones,
you won't even notice it and it will protect your Dick.
My knees are always pretend you're drilling armbars yeah,
Dick.
Hey,
you'll enjoy.
Well,
the other thing about the tie cups where the people would use them for leverage
like they would say that,
ah,
yeah,
a leverage point for an arm bar or something like that.
It's like you have a rock there.
You could break a stick over,
you know,
it's like it's not back mount with a body triangle.
She's like hit in the spine or mount like sometimes people mount you and
they'll,
they'll grape grapevine or they'll,
yeah,
they'll,
they'll get that.
That Dick Right on your sternum called the Dick Grinder.
They get pressed the hard steel right in your solar plexus.
That sucks dude.
Okay.
He keeps doing that.
A bonus single.
I know that he also,
what Eddie,
Eddie,
you need get on one of these natural things.
Be able to wake your ass right.
Yeah.
You fucking around with that wide awake Tuesday.
I already drank a cup of coffee and I was like,
how does,
how does that compare to that?
To that?
I did a podcast,
which is fucked.
I did a podcast with take two weeks ago.
I am not exaggerating.
I think he drank for these during the podcast.
He was so,
any had coffee,
regular cross talking like just wouldn't shut the fuck up.
He couldn't,
he was like,
he's on cocaine.
Guy Is fucking crazy beard.
He's an animal.
Was all excited about everything.
Super doozy asked him.
He's a super busy as he's on crank natural coffee breaks her about everything.
Fuck yeah,
man.
I love best days the best.
He's such a fun guy.
He said,
I like vibrant guy like so happy and fucking,
and he'll get deep.
You will get d.
We got a slice of pizza the other day and this full fucking sat me down and got
deep.
I was like,
damn man,
I'm just trying to eat my pizza.
Get the fucking Benson with the tape.
Oh Shit.
Lost.
Lost that last bit out on top.
Looking for that Darcel again.
He was nasty with it,
man.
He likes to up front show for sure.
And fight bend.
There you go.
There you're actually two feet.
Nice.
Oh,
right hand.
Oh Great.
Elbows.
Oh,
he's a little more polished,
right with his,
uh,
his combinations.
Yeah.
Especially more fluidity to a mosfet dolls.
Punching dude.
Ben's here is out of control now.
Oh,
that was perfect timing.
Nice timing.
That's like Dow right back up to his feeds.
All Greasy.
The mosfet doll is nasty.
He's a motherfucker nasty.
Did you know?
I wouldn't mind seeing it,
although Ben did beat him.
But Mazda Dover's,
Brandon Thatch.
Oh,
got yourself a mother fucking son.
How's that still come Joseph with the,
with the weight cutting now that he can't use an IV anymore.
Does that have an effect on him at all?
He's a big ass one.
Saturday and B also not that disciplined,
so,
so hopefully,
hopefully he's doing.
Yeah.
And so looking for the Kimora here,
just in his face
driving me fucking nuts.
Well look,
it's going to have no,
Oh,
boss play Guido.
This,
it's true.
Look at this shit
mission.
A corn hole.
That's what we saw in the video.
He's just going to pass.
She gonna push light down and pass.
Do you think so?
Yup.
Not a Benson's good at this.
He's not Benson and keep that left leg and play
all case pass.
No written that.
Well,
no.
I had to let go.
He had all that goes on that left leg.
Yeah,
but he got lazy with it.
he did.
He forgot about it and never got hit once though.
It's true.
Yeah.
He didn't control his posture the entire time.
That's where it's like,
oh,
oh wow.
Yeah.
This would be a good time to plug Ebi.
Oh Shit.
Sunday,
December 13th I five seven top two biggest release the countdown show.
Just go to youtube.
Ebi.
Five countdown shows dope too.
Did you watch it?
Yeah,
when you sent me the link that way.
Cool.
Cool man.
Yeah.
Good man.
Googley movie.
Watch the check side.
Awesome.
That's great.
Yeah man.
I'm Paul.
Half Hour.
Oh,
hobbies story.
How did he,
how he took it in last minute but now he's at 55 different story.
Different story.
Eddie Cummings going is that one 45 champion?
Now he's going up to 55 but no one is,
no one gives a shit cause he actually did one 70 and tapped out and Rico coco
and he tapped out.
The one of my guys move so well up and down and wait like that.
He's so good with heel hooks,
man that
he could,
he could do major damage at 1701505145 doesn't,
isn't hard for it must be hard for him to make one 45 though he doesn't look
like a 445 pound guy.
Cummins probably walks around one 70 65 once,
but he did.
He did same day.
Weigh in one 45 Ebi for that's impressive.
And that's on youtube to all one,
two,
three and four are all free on youtube.
Uh,
Ebi five's going to be on paper,
feels butoh videos.com/ebi fun,
powerful,
Ai Greatest.
And then without a doubt the greatest format ever for grappling.
It's hundred person comparable and nailed down.
It's so perfect because it's very exciting up until the final part cause
everybody's worried about the final part.
But you solve the stalemate part and put them in bad positions and have them
alternate.
Alternate between having the back mount with an over under and having spiderweb.
It's beautiful.
It's a best they can actually get so excited to actually get the choice.
Yeah,
dude,
I might have a heart attack if I drink another one,
but I'm going to do,
you're going to be fun.
And then we got Denny coming back to defend his title.
So per call pose and then Nathan,
Nathan Orchard at one 55 that's a different animal because it's hard for him to
make 55,
he's going to be the tallest,
longest uh man and with,
with his dead orchards and his leg,
but he is more effective on a Ya Ya edcc gold medal is honey.
I asked Connie.
It's going to be Sarah.
I want to get a fucking shirt from him cause he's got team constrictor and I was
taught that was dope as shit.
I was wanting to ask him when they were going into the octagon I got,
but it was like he was fought on the undercard so I never got a chance to like
get back to like Yo man dude,
I wish she was one of them team kits.
Oh she's team honey constrict.
Usually that's your new shirt team.
Honey Dick team honeydew.
Connie,
this is honey dick boy than you.
You'd need a team,
honey Dick Shirt,
man.
Sure.
I get so many tweets during the UFC.
Oh,
this is UFC honey day.
That's all I get.
I'm like,
say that Hashtag honey Dick.
It's right.
This is the last round.
The final round.
Oh my hospital.
Serious grenache grappling.
Yeah.
So the Darren Cruickshank fight like as soon as you started grappling with
Crookshanks just shut all that down.
Shut him down.
Christian.
He's fighting soon.
Right?
The Detroit superstar.
I heard he did some polling for PE.
Did he?
Was that that you might have to look that up Jamie.
I'm,
I don't want to shit.
Look at them almost.
He's trapped.
He's caught.
He's caught take that keeps spinning.
Spins out.
He got it.
Wow.
Very good defense.
That is not good.
Get to it.
Oh Shit.
He keeps going to it.
Ben's confidence in.
Okay.
Like so that,
that's a really close situation.
Right.
Then ask this core for something that sounds good to me.
Grappling.
I mean that's serious danger,
right?
That's like a knockdown.
Yes.
I mean just because he doesn't get stunned and like he doesn't get brain damage
from that.
That it shouldn't.
It shouldn't factory like that was it.
That's as closest.
Then they'll fight is getting knocked down.
Very.
Wasn't that,
maybe it wasn't that close,
but that's a little different.
Like if you do an arm bar and he'd get out of the arm bar,
but they did hyper extended,
break it or pop,
you're still damaged and I'll tell you,
get out of it.
You're still good.
After you got his back and he took them down past his guard dominated grappling
and then,
and then almost choked him.
Yes,
ten eight but like from this kind of position,
whether it gets,
and then he throws a guillotine,
but then they're still cutting dude,
grandmas and [inaudible] Ben.
Ben was in trouble.
He's not going to go through all that if it's not tight,
but he kept,
that's got,
it's got to count for something.
Oh,
kicked to the bottom and taking down son.
Holy Shit.
This takes out of his take down defense on point.
Word flying.
Fuck man.
Really Ben for his team.
I'll ask to,
here's some cheeks on him.
He's got some thick ass thighs,
like an NFL running back.
Dude,
he had some of the best ground and pound where he would stand in the guard and
just drop bombs and state almost in a horse horse stance.
I remember Wec.
He's rolled the tiled.
Yeah.
Oh,
lost the position.
score.
This fucking fight.
I should've kept that tired,
dad.
Yeah,
he's getting tired and pence thriving.
They're so slippery.
It's crazy.
All that grace
grabbing the fuck out of him right now.
What would that crux shake stuff at your own risk?
Why?
I'm right,
right.
Unconfirmed rumor in 2008 they don't call them Detroit soup.
This some shit.
That's what I heard.
Is it the regular kind and it said something about solo and some other name.
I didn't want low like Jackson Solo jacking and there's nothing wrong that a
little jacked for pillar man in the future.
There's going to be Photoshop,
so realistic and CGI,
so realistic on everybody's computer.
We're all doing it.
Everyone be liking it or not.
There's going to be videos.
You get that stuff.
Oh,
well there's been means Amiga sucking Dick left and right,
but that's his pictures.
They're going to be able to do that shit with video and no time.
You know,
like any video you watched today,
highly suspect of a news event,
a monster attack,
bigfoot in the woods,
they can make anything getting started.
They can make anything happen now and in the future,
like you're going to,
you're going to be able to watch every celebrity you've ever wanted to watch.
Fuck,
I'm looking forward to that.
Jennifer Lawrence.
Dude,
I'm fucking in.
Marilyn Monroe sold Traci lords and all of them together in a room.
I'm man going after Chris Farley gonna blow.
Yeah,
he's getting fucking David's Bait.
Saki,
Chris Farley's dig all.
That's all.
That's real.
Then you could get the holograms right where it's like a three d right in front
of the Washer,
right in front of you.
You build it and it'll be like,
it'll be so good.
The holograms be so good.
You want to able a see through them to look like real three dimensional objects
in front of you can't wait for this.
Yeah,
you're just going to be shooting loads in the loads.
We'll go through them will disappear.
You guys won't really about there.
It's going to,
all the loads are going to be there.
You just have your own loads.
Digital loads.
Like if you were jerking off,
it's like a litter box,
a cat litter box.
You just jerk and knew it.
It's going to be crazy.
Well we're going to see in the next 20 years as far as like the ability to
artificially manipulate images and make thing like that magic leap.
You ever seen that magic leap technology they're working on?
They don't know how they're doing it like cause they haven't revealed it yet,
but they show like this uh,
elephant dancing and this person's hand.
They show this little girl like sitting on a bed and a four inch ballerinas
dancing in front of her on the bed and it looks real and fun.
It's insane.
Holding something.
I don't know.
I don't know how it works that it.
See the thing is in the images that they show,
they haven't fully revealed it yet,
but in the images that they show people doing it,
the people don't have any goggles on.
Theirs is like,
it's not like there's some technology that they have.
We see it through like ski goggles,
like look at this,
look at this.
This is like under a dex shot directly through magic leap technology.
So like they're,
they,
they have these holograms that they can project from the air like that.
Like look at that.
I want that some Avatar shit right now.
Like you're sitting there and eating and above you.
Is the solar system spinning around?
Well,
the,
the ones that they showed,
they had one of them where it was a whale on the beach.
It was crazy.
Did you see in Robin Williams a will,
he has a contract where they can't use any of his name or likeness for future
holograms or any technology like this.
How smart is that?
He's like,
I don't be recreated when technology can do that kind of stuff.
He doesn't want to be like two pocket Coachella.
Yeah.
He doesn't want any of that.
I'm pretty smart to think of that shit.
They should have like a real time where the earth is in relation to the other
planets,
like real time.
Pretty smart that they pretend that you're looking at the planets because they
put it right over that girls titties.
Yeah.
I am a,
I'm looking at the solar system.
Meanwhile,
ferocious mound road says,
aw,
so lovely.
Is there some late uh,
ted type show with the latest technology and jerking off?
I wouldn't.
You want to watch that happen ted?
Who's winning?
Oh Shit.
Shit could've won.
It could've gone either way.
I can't.
Yeah.
Wow.
I didn't watch it close enough.
But split decision sounds right.
Yeah.
Oh,
there's his wife and
new baby man.
The cardio,
he doesn't want it.
It went right to why did they go right to Mosbey doll?
Why would they do that?
It's a terrible,
hold on.
Maybe we can be in the biggest stage in the world.
It's the nature of the beast.
If there was a change there now he seems like he's accepted into defeat.
Okay.
It's weird.
They went right to him though.
Never seen it before.
First time ever
probably notice that
someone fucked up
100% you can't go to him first talk to the winter.
It does seem weird or maybe they want to get
any floor and in the,
we didn't listen to the commentary unless he was saying in the commentary that
he thought that Mosfet all
just doesn't sense
his fight against,
damn,
he's straight up.
Can we get some Denver talking to Benson and Korean like he doesn't understand
English?
Ben's Mom's Korean.
I know.
Can I get an amen?
Amen.
It was arms of tremendous,
huge.
It looks great.
How's the interpreter gonna actually
keep this bus rolling.
Bus.
Whoa.
Bounce
already your best performance,
especially in regards to your striking man.
This was the sharpest I've ever seen you up.
Who?
I disagree,
but we weren't really paying attention that much.
I saw Kenny was on the stick.
Fondling is luscious beard.
Let me pontificate,
right?
What did all what's then we'll see.
What he does is go,
how call it though Jorge George,
and also stepping up and giving me this fight.
A bad,
it's bad buck son of a gun.
Is that what he said?
But he was trying so hard not to cuss their
ass son of a gun,
a bad,
but son of a gun.
Bad bottom.
So a bad booty.
Bandit,
bad booty band.
People might boom,
boom.
Dick bandits texted to me,
tweet it to more often than not,
when I connect myself to you guys in some way,
Dick bandits.
What does that mean?
It's just a song that we sing on.
Sing it for me.
How's it go?
It goes big.
Dig bandits.
Bandits.
Waste the robber bags and your Dick.
I don't understand Alban dudes
do it.
These live shows,
they asked us to sing it.
Me and Brian are starting this big date bandits.
This live shows was to be so silly,
so fun,
so fun.
A lot of them.
You didn't.
You do one Wednesday night,
Wednesday night.
They're all sold out,
man.
Then amazing.
The West Coast tour,
they're all selling great.
Like I was talking to before.
I'm just worried about the Seattle and Portland cause they're huge theaters for
us.
You know what?
800 900 seats.
That's big.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
And what about a Denver?
Have you done Denver?
No,
we're doing a mid uh,
mid west run and an east coast run later into you got to do east coast,
east coast.
We're going New York,
Boston,
I mean all over.
What are you guys doing for Boston?
Which I'm not sure.
Just do the Wilbur.
Really?
Yeah.
People get crazy.
Go 1200 seats for sure.
Come with it.
I'm ready.
April 1st and second.
Are you there?
I'm already booked tickets.
I'm doing shit way in advance now.
That's all the know what the UFC,
the problem is like UFC doesn't announce their,
their schedule like as far in advance as usually do book,
like theaters and stuff like that.
So like a lot of times like wall come into a place,
like they'll announce it like a couple months out and I go,
let me see if I could find a place where I to work.
It's too late.
Yeah.
Everything.
Now.
Look,
if I'm lucky,
I can get the comedy club on like a Friday night,
but a lot of times I can't even do that.
I have seen in the late shit.
Fuck this noise.
I like comedy clubs though.
I bet.
I'm just so you come into,
especially with the UFC is in town.
Everyone see your shit?
Yeah.
This is what I want to see this.
Fuck God damn.
I hope this actually happens.
It's happening.
God got it happened.
Aldo and motherfucking McGregor.
Dude,
we got to have the fight before when Greg,
it puts more tattoos on to that.
That tiger one.
He's all right,
man.
He's got to tell him he covered up the slow down.
ABS.
Take it easy.
Why would you cover your abs up?
Very well known.
He has nice abs,
but why would you do that?
The Tattoo so good.
It looks three d.
It looked like a tattoo.
I get in my belly.
It's too much.
That's too much.
And why?
Why a tiger on the stomach?
It's just loves tigers.
It just allows you to do it.
I don't know,
man.
Maybe it's like some spirit allocates this boom.
You're not showing the,
the short haired roads pick.
They don't have,
they didn't update the trend haired vanzant.
What's it is trimmed there.
It's perfect.
That's exactly how much you cut off.
I'm not kidding.
I'm not mad at it.
Good for her.
You go girl.
Oh,
she would look dot.
With a shaved head.
Please.
They'll grow.
Would look high with a crew cut.
She's hot as fuck.
They're both one's fun.
I'm on board.
Yeah.
I dated a girl who was completely shaven bald when I first moved out to
California.
It was by choice and yeah,
she's hot.
She would wear weird wigs and shit.
She was cool.
She was hot.
She must've been on heroin or she was just crazy.
She was from Norway.
She was a wild cat.
Oh Jesus.
Louise's you don't shave your head just for the Lord.
That's like some cleansing heroin recovery shit.
She's,
she was smart as fuck too.
Very interesting person.
I bet she was a freaking machine.
Listen,
I'm not a kiss and tell type of guy,
but um,
but it was weird with doggystyle the back of the head like shaved.
It was like odd.
Like at least it was,
we were looking at each other.
I could see like you're pretty,
you're a girl even though you don't have any here.
Not been there with muscular chicks.
Am I decos Doggie stoma did not like that.
I was in my twenties I was till it was,
it was too young to handle weirdness.
I agree.
Now I was 26 you can't handle the weirdness of 26 that'll fuck your whole game
up then.
You're just too weak.
You're not ready for it.
Yeah,
you're not ready.
Any one thing could kill your boner and he need to experience that.
You went to fucking spiral of panic.
It was a good ass fight,
man.
That was really good fight.
Good card man overall for whatever.
We paid attention to shit,
man.
For together five o'clock in the morning some days just having imagine that
Flintstones on or some shit doesn't watch Fox News and talk with the girls.
Deliver the news bunch of chicks with skirts on talking about them.
CNN brings the heat though with check today.
Well I want to do it in the morning.
I don't really think so.
It's just the way the operate.
Well if they had to probably compete with Fox because Fox is bringing in them,
she demos those blonde white
and tell it and Telemundo,
if you watch news on Telemundo,
I can't handle it to pay attention to the news.
All I'm seating and Rita's given out the news that per ruby red lipstick final
round with national scam callers.
I wish I got that channel.
Is it Jack?
My Shit wrong.
Do they have that on youtube that I'm the Spanish ladies doing the weather.
Do they have them on Youtube?
Have you seen that Spanish girl on Telemundo doing the weather Spec?
Fuck her re Dickus she's an angel
angel.
The sexy Yama.
No,
let's not get crazy that twice.
Yeah,
I get it.
But she's a legit Latin Angel Man.
Yes.
She liked crossed over cause she was like on TMZ and shit.
She's so fine.
Like there she is.
Oh look at that ass son.
Oh my goodness.
Is that real?
Yeah,
it's a weird ass major.
Bravo from Mexico.
It's a weird ass weird and that it makes my Dick Dance.
We're definitely filling up with blood,
but that's what you mean by weird.
Look at her ass in the right hands.
The last frame.
I'm like God,
it's like it's insane.
I don't know at
first of all it's really rude that she sticks it out like that.
It's,
we understand.
It's kind of weird at the right cheek is perfect.
Eddie.
Is that funny that a girl is totally allowed sticker ass cheeks out like that?
Like if a guy like walks around like this,
like pop makes chest out and throws his arms
back.
The guy's a loser
like she can,
if she stands like that for long,
she's going to blow it disk.
That's so dangerous.
You can't carry anything with you.
So she tried to carry like a lunchbox.
She might fuck it.
You have a herniated disc due.
She's my girl.
She's walking around like that all the time.
Carrier.
Whereas
click that,
so the right hand side
off the charts in Sunny Garcia,
God oof,
row Civ,
yet you know there's that,
that Latin body that voluptuous like what's that girl
shit?
Oh my God,
look at that video.
I'm telling you bro.
Yes.
That's a weather girl.
Fucking weather from Mexico.
Fuck.
Okay,
so she doesn't even have it.
Dell like arch your back is that guy who's that guy?
Was that a guy talking about her?
Yeah,
he's breaking down her booty.
Y'All watch out for that.
Live on TV.
Good Lord.
It makes our weather girls look like fucking shit.
Fucking pro tip to the guy doing the video.
We don't need to see you.
We can hear you just voice over.
I don't need this.
This is not necessary,
sir.
This is interrupting with the girl's booty.
Yeah,
we don't want to see your Scott Hass.
Jamie,
please get away from him quickly find another video.
There must be really videos.
This is outrageous.
What does that dead fish or some shit.
Yeah,
that booties.
Oh my God.
There's a compilation of our,
what are the girl has a weather who has a body like that on planet earth doing
the weather.
A good girl like her.
So important.
It is very important.
I've met their ratings are through the roof.
Jesus.
Meanwhile,
in America we get that fucking guy.
The black guy lost all the weight.
[inaudible]
get that black guy.
Oh my God.
It's so stupid.
Look at her.
Oh my God.
It
looks like she's topless right there.
No,
no,
no.
It's just read.
That's crazy.
You find the hotter weather girl and come talk to me.
Yeah.
I don't think,
well,
girls don't get hotter.
There's like a level of hot.
They just get different.
I agree.
No,
they don't have great,
it's like a nice,
yeah,
just said,
it gets to a certain point where like,
okay,
this is just hot.
She's just how good he is.
Just denial.
She's a 10 looks that goes there,
but there are,
that's one of the most hilarious things about guys online.
Elbows are way to point a bro.
That's the standard one that people always walk off.
But there's,
there's so many guys that little talk shit about like unbelievably smoking hot
chicks.
They talk mad shit online.
She ain't nothing to me,
bro.
Maybe a six.
Maybe it's six.
It's six broke
bro out real turds.
Shut up.
Shut up
dude.
The Internet and social media is fucking their HSAs are the most,
like Rhonda came,
gone social media right now.
She'd stay off for her.
She needs a post.
What if she laughs?
What if she's having fun with it?
Oh,
hey,
look at me.
She's not 100% I'd be devastated.
That's horrible shit man.
You know,
that's a,
that's a kind of Keio too that you got to go,
man,
we hopefully she recovers 100% and she's back and everything's great,
but you don't have to recover 100% from a Kale like that.
Like head kick.
That's a,
that's a bad knockout.
But what about,
what about you?
You know,
obviously health issues.
What about your confidence?
Invincible.
You think Europe,
the bathroom.
I forgot to plan.
Then all of a sudden it's like,
Nah,
you're just like the rest of us.
Yeah,
I mean that that certainly can be a factor,
but confidence.
I feel like maybe you could get that back through meditation or through hypnosis
or through something or through just hardworking determination maybe,
but the physical stuff,
like if it's bad,
it's bad.
I agree.
Look at Tj grant is a good example.
Tj Grant got one concussion.
He was in line to fight for the title.
He has never fought since and now he's,
we went back to work.
Is he done gun job like a mine in Canada?
Gog.
Tj Grant.
Remember Tj grant lit up gray.
Maynard looked fucking fantastical.
Surreal.
His elbows.
Devastating.
Ridiculous.
Misty technique.
Nasty technique.
Tough fucking guy.
He's working at fucking Hortons or some shit.
He's get those mining jobs like in Alberta.
They make good money.
Did he give him,
I mean he had a good chance to be a world champ.
Could have been a world champ.
I mean,
it might not have won the first time at the title,
but he had a,
he had real,
real legit worldclass Gill.
100% yeah.
And he could have made a good robot.
Chris Holdsworth same thing.
Concussion.
He's,
he's got,
he's got a problem.
He hasn't fought since Danny.
Danny have an ACL two or something like that.
So kind of surgery kind of surgery.
I remember Joseph Valtellina,
he glory champion,
how to relinquish his title,
concussions.
If Connor has a bad loss,
if he gets like chaos out and gets caught real bad head kick or something.
I mean damn.
Hey go one man.
I think like,
look at how,
first of all,
Holly homes all over the place now she's,
she's on every fucking new show.
She's over ESPN and all these different sports shows.
She easily could have a gigantic paper view in our next card.
Like people are excited about her and only if it gets Rhonda may be,
but if it's not Rhonda,
she might have half a million.
It's horrible if she has a good fight.
But the amount of positive like publicity she got out of that and the mount she
was everyone's at.
But people are gonna want to see her fight again.
And if they see her fight,
something like Cyborg may be.
Yeah,
if you are at one 40 if she says I'll step up to one 40 and she fight Cyborg at
one 40 or even,
I think she fought as high as one 50 when she was kickboxing.
I don't,
I don't think she'll,
you know,
I love Holly or barking.
She's great.
I don't think should ever be as big as stars.
Rhonda.
No Ma,
how many fights you might not be.
This had this perfect storm of personality,
hatred and destroying girls in 16 seconds where it was like this perfect storm
where she crossed over to the possibility of Rothrock,
man,
she's going to be like the greatest and being movie rock.
That's hilarious.
She was like a a forms champion.
Cynthia rothrock do remember her Anda well,
Kathy long actually,
she was a kickbox kickboxer Carano Holly Holm.
I Dunno.
I'm just fucked her.
I would be a crazy fight if Gina Carano came back.
That makes sense.
Let's,
let's play devil's advocate,
let's say,
and there's a good chance it's not even,
I'm not even hating,
but let's say Connor were to loose,
who's the UFC superstar?
Who's the judge?
I'll do if he beats him.
Oh yeah,
no,
not in America.
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones be the next [inaudible] can't be a mega star,
but Anderson was,
I don't know,
man.
I'd make,
because he's smaller.
Is that what it is?
I think so.
That's the way America works.
If it's English is terrible,
he'll be on or not the level.
It could also level positions then for how long?
Middleweights been forever.
And then outdoors is kind of still the only and the new.
But if all Dover questions,
Mcgregor,
people will just make comparisons to Rhonda.
Like,
Oh,
you guys overrated.
Yes,
yes.
That's definitely will.
Hundred percent.
And I'm like,
oh,
UFC.
Just the hype train bubbles floating is the hype is real.
Like you look at his fights,
there's no hype I lost in 10 years.
She fucks.
It's real.
But,
but,
but both Conor and Aldo,
both of them,
that's real.
I mean you look at Conor destroying Mendez,
beating the fuck out of Seaver blast and [inaudible] out in the first round.
I mean it doesn't compare to what Joe's Ale,
no Brandao Kao but he's legitimately legitimately skilled.
100% one was like that's an exciting fight.
The the what the fuck is gonna Happen?
Factor is very high,
right?
You look at that fight,
it's like what the fuck is going to happen?
It's huge.
We could speculate all day,
but the best is what's going to happen after whoever wins.
You'll be able to go online and they'll be the,
I told you so dude's hundred percent lined up lined up.
So weird man gets on social media way to fucking go.
Joe Rogan,
Eddie Bravo and Ben let it,
I don't mind that,
that doesn't bother me.
[inaudible] is kind of crazy.
Is like the for Roche's meeting.
They're given Rhonda for real.
She asked for it though.
Like when like when you post that night before the fight,
like you fucking fake ass bitch.
Hey man,
relax.
So when you act like,
then you don't shake hands and you're an actual,
you know,
when you,
when you go after these girls who don't have a reason to,
then people are like,
you know what?
Now you're being a bully.
And so when you leave it at that level,
she was a good word.
Goons are legit word,
good word.
You know,
when I started using that word again,
Eddie Bravo,
uh,
his back before we knew that a north south choke was legit and Monson got
someone in north south choke and you said he googled them.
[inaudible]
has done it using that word every,
this was a long time ago.
Cause think about how long north south chokes had been legit.
But there was a while where we didn't know the north south choke was legit
months and made that shit and Monsi is such a tank and you just assumed that he
gooned up just trying to like,
come on man,
you're just squeezing on his head and plants.
Come on.
That's goon squad son.
Meanwhile you're really good at that.
That's my shit.
I love,
I've loved North South chose certain guys that love north south and I'll put
them on every car.
When was a beast?
Choke is like all the elements of the head and arm choke was always my favorite.
But you don't put pressure on your own neck.
Like you don't have as much pressure on your own neck.
It's like a cell is really good as you get to save it all fucked up mom.
Chokes man honey,
y'all,
y'all actually got one in in the UFC?
Yes he did.
Yeah,
I think he did too.
Yeah.
You don't call people goon anymore?
No.
It's a nasty technique.
Super Nasty.
Who Else fucking did that?
Someone did.
That was a honker narrow.
Did he nail one?
Did he land one recently?
I feel like
I'm smarter than him cause he did that.
Somebody,
somebody got that north south choke recently.
I don't remember.
But that's it.
So whatever,
it's a super effective technique.
But when you said it,
you know like he goon to him and I was like,
I've everything I made that up I think.
Oh,
I don't think you did either,
but you said it to me.
It's a great term.
But yeah,
it's like the term just brought it back and
she,
I think you're totally right that she brought it on herself and a lot of way and
what will make someone excited about a guy like Floyd Mayweather pulling it off
and laying those stacks of paper.
If he did get chaos.
Q,
imagine if Manny same shell landed or bombings shit,
he gets so much God.
But meanwhile when Manny got knocked out,
but man,
one,
Mel Marquez,
yes.
Mean there was almost none of that.
There's was like,
whoa.
It was like a meme here.
You felt bad for him because he's a good person.
I mean,
or as you don't have bad intentions.
He's like,
well,
I hope the fight goes good.
Floyd is,
I already go back to everybody.
All right,
cool man.
Thank you Jesus.
I was weird,
Dan,
for as much as she is getting kind of meme don and,
and people messing with her and whatnot,
would you,
would you say that's probably the most expensive
head kick knockout anybody's ever been paid?
Um,
yeah,
probably right.
No one ever probably made as much money as she did.
Like when you think about like she has a percentage of pay per view buys that
was over a million paper view bars.
No Way.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Some of the GSP GSPS Brock's.
Yeah,
they,
Brock,
Brock Brock.
Probably the biggest,
there's still no,
the rematch with Holly Holm.
We'll probably break records.
That's why Holly's not going to fight anyone else because that's the UFC fight.
But wouldn't you say that from just the injury alone?
Just to for the head kick alone,
she needs,
like when Freddy Roach was willing to work with PAC yogan after the one,
when Mel Marcus fight,
he said,
I want you to take a year off.
I agree with Rhonda.
Go do all the movies you want a year.
You think a year,
you're not going to wait a year.
It's gonna have to fight somewhere else.
The other thing is the pressure from the UFC and Dana and Ronda being so close
is this can be tougher to be like,
no,
I won't take a year off.
Right.
But she needs a significant amount of time a year.
It should be several months with no contact,
nothing.
Nothing now,
now,
now is are the people surrounding her if they're looking out for her best
interest,
I thinking allowed her to do that.
Let's see who's really in her corner there.
Of course you say,
take a year off.
Let's just clear everything.
Take a year off and do your thing and she was a strong will.
She might think she can come back sooner than she can write and that's where
your fucking people around you should be like,
no,
we know you want to.
Here's what we're,
this is the game plan.
She needs to be like,
here's the game plan.
You're off,
but a of everything except wrestling.
She should move to Iowa by a ranch.
Just can't fly him here.
Buy a ranch that you got to sell that ranch after
ranch.
Russel Russel Russel Russel's selling some ships,
Houma for a couple of months,
Iowa for another couple months.
Illinois.
Just hang out with all them wrestlers or just make a shitload of movies for a
year and then just do your thing.
There's some good wrestling in California.
You have plenty of good wrestlers get away from all this shit.
She needs to go.
She knows she needs a break,
man.
Kornfield yeah.
Kornfield and run.
Run it like or anything like that.
Kevin Costner,
movie field of dreams to have for the HPL.
Rhonda movie comes out just,
Oh man,
that's tough.
That's tough to sell now rowdy.
It isn't.
If she comes back,
if she comes back,
this is the best.
It's better than ever.
Now.
Only if she went to combat everyone.
Rocky lawsuit against Mr Too.
The first time they fought twice in rocky three and he got his ass kicked in the
first one.
Do you know
what I'm talking about?
Listening to this.
That's how you get people excited.
Hi,
you got one hour sleep at my gun.
Ambient.
Hey,
rocky got beat.
He got knocked out one hour,
20 minute mark.
I thought how much speed was going to lose because the movie
wasn't a,
right now there's still 40 in the the movie.
This is where she comes back.
There's a comeback.
This is when she moved to Iowa instead of rocky.
Go in the fucking mountains.
She's there in Iowa by yourself,
right?
That part of the,
they actually show,
you know what she's working on her autobiography.
What?
Now?
She's got the best part of it.
Well,
she had the a
book already,
right?
You've got the book.
The book's already come out.
They don't this here.
There's no end chapter in that.
They need to fucking fill in extra chapter downloads or clients to beat a dead
go rocky three of them.
You know what's really crazy is that she's the favorite in the rematch.
Yeah,
it's pretty nuts.
I don't know what,
that's fucking insane.
What are you basing that?
Who's making the odds?
That seems some,
some,
some of the already odds for a fight that's not going to have them.
Yeah,
they do that all the time.
Like there's odds for a John Deasy already,
but you can't,
can you bet?
Can you throw money to get bet yet?
No.
So it's nice yards.
They establish odds just to,
what does a jerk off probably.
Here's a look.
Yeah,
Jack off online.
It seems to me that you can't make Holly anything but the favorite.
When I put in the mansion,
we saw them fight.
We saw how it played out.
We saw strong Holly.
Look,
we saw Holly Take Rhonda down.
We saw Holly completely light are upstanding.
I knew like early in the first round Rhonda was in trouble.
Trouble.
Yes.
I see that.
Look on her face.
Well it's also the hollies movement.
Agree.
She was so light on her feet and she was countering so well.
It's like invest.
Rhonda lands a bump.
She did land one good left hook,
but it was right before Holly took her down like she landed one good laptop is
old boxing fights and she eats some fucking shots from world class box and
opponents and just keeps on keeping on.
Did you see the one fight where she got Koi?
Yes.
That's hard to watch.
The fights great though.
It's,
it's back and forth like a motherfucker.
It's a brutal,
brutal Kale through the,
through the ropes.
Dude.
I had a guy in Starbucks asked me,
I wanted to slap the fuck.
I'm fill this scolding hot coffee on him.
He goes,
hey man,
heard the fight was fixed.
Oh my God,
I get that a ton.
Hey,
I heard that fight was fixed.
You fucking moron.
Yeah.
Rhonda was like,
let's fix this fight and this fight.
You're going to outclass me on the feet.
And then the second round fucking kicked my head off because that's how we're,
we want this to be so dumb.
They shouldn't be able to talk.
There's some people that are walking amongst us that might as well be like
shrews out in the forest,
straight up foraging for roots and berries.
They might as well be just,
but they live in a society where they can get a job doing some stupid move this
box over there,
oak,
her world.
And they go and do that and then they get health insurance and then they
survive.
And then they fucking go to the hospital
and someone way smarter than them fixes whatever things wrong with that man.
And they pretend like they're people,
but they're not the like talking shrewd.
This guy was like mad cause I looked down and go,
you serious?
And he goes,
dude,
it's not,
it's not crazy to think that I'm like fucking insane.
That's just stupid as fuck.
Stupid as fuck.
That's like you shouldn't be able to comment on finding.
If you think that that looks like a fake fight,
like that's like me looking at an airplane going,
how's that flying bro?
It's metal.
I know,
bro.
It's Ma.
How's it was something metal fly.
It's crazy.
Shut the fuck up.
Like it's really that stupid to think there's surveys,
conspiracy theory where they were like,
Alex have Rhonda loose.
No.
That's the worst thing that could happen for them.
Conspiracies.
That was a perfect segway into tower seven if you think Rocky's chem trails,
rocky
real
movies are made of.
She's in the middle of a real movie.
No,
I get it now.
She's in the middle of some real shit.
Some real shit.
This is,
oh,
we totally understand what you're talking about.
Rocky.
Three minutes.
You look at it a long time ago we got it.
Holly Holm is clubber lane.
If you look at the difference between her life just a couple of months ago and
her life now,
boy,
she's aunt after Brazil.
She's on top of the fucking world,
right?
She's cheered in Brazil Beats Batchko.
Hey,
by Kao,
the whole thing is just spectacular.
The whole world falls at her feet.
Was it ESPN or sports illustrated called it the greatest female athlete ever.
She's on the cover of ring.
Who Was it?
Was it cover ring magazine?
I was either ESPN horse follows those trade one of them,
but whatever it is,
she went an sp for fighter of the year,
beat up Floyd Mayweather and then Holly Holm said,
that's cool.
Check this out.
And then shotgun
kicked that bitch and fucking 1997 it was not.
Here we are.
That head kick to men.
The way she did it where Rhonda was like stumbling back and she didn't even see
it.
Common cause like Eve Edward Dude,
every person camps,
every person who tells me in her camp,
every person goes,
yeah bro,
no injuries.
Well No,
I get that.
But her brain's probably pretty fucked up.
No Man,
no injuries.
Like,
oh my look at me.
Can you say that?
How can anybody say that it is?
It's,
it's,
it's dangerous for the sport to pretend that that wasn't a devastating,
devastating care.
It's dangerous.
That's the Kale in the history of combat sports for women,
not for men,
Cro,
cop and Gonzaga,
Gonzaga,
Cro,
cop,
all crossfit's and pride that was dealt colon so big.
The reason it's so big,
we never seen someone of that caliber like to see someone that has that inner
prime star get knocked the fuck out by him.
And that way you're right in that way.
You're right.
Yeah.
That'd be like if v toward did that to John Jones when they fought for the
title.
Yes,
exactly.
Tour like rock holding them.
Then you're like,
what the fuck?
But when cro cop and Gonzaga fight,
it was big,
but cro cop was on fucking the on TMZ every day,
you know?
Right,
right,
right.
Yes.
Star wise.
Yeah.
It's the biggest one ever.
And it was pretty God damn devastating.
And then when you consider the fact that she got lit up for all those,
all those hard shots in the first round taken down,
taken that,
but really the,
the,
the Chatelet she ate to her face and then the big head kick comes in the second
round.
Like boom,
after missing that crazy wild left hook.
Holly ducks under everyone's like,
no,
her lips fine.
It doesn't matter man.
No,
her lip got fucking split.
She has stitches.
Okay.
On the ground.
Fairly was looking for,
Holly has the arm hooked.
She didn't have the arm hooked like it wasn't,
it wasn't really a controls.
Yeah,
but the thing about like the Kao is it's not about what you've seen in the
outside.
Obviously her nose is bleeding or she had blood in her mouth.
Whatever stitches she had to have on her lip,
that's all going to be,
that's fine.
But inside the dome that's,
that's a head kick.
Brains or brains.
Honestly,
the face plant to face plant was
the last time you sold a females get fucked up.
Like Yo and Holly's got some thighs on her dude.
I bet there's a lot of pop to those kids because those like the way she bounces
around the octagon,
that's some serious,
did you call it before on a,
on a sh like Jimmy Kimmel.
She's like,
she thinks she's going to kick me in the head but it's not.
I don't think so.
You're going to get me frustrated.
She called her at all.
She really did.
You know,
I think you have to live a stoic,
singular existence to be a fighter at the highest level when you're fighting
someone is dangerous as like a Holly Holm and that's what Holly did.
She lived a stoic singular existed.
She lived for a purpose.
You know,
she did her media obligations but she trained like a fucking wild beast.
She didn't have any movies.
Tractions didn't have all this other stuff since she was 15 and the same staff
and she's gotten nasty skills man.
And she's based in real championship fights multiple times like you and while we
have,
why didn't we see this coming?
I agree.
Will you go back to the fight podcasts the last no,
we all said it was ridiculous.
I am done.
I thought that Amanda Nunez will be more dangerous.
Fire hunted ditches.
See,
she'd just finished a Sara McMann.
He's got Kale power.
I agree with luck.
Cat Zingano up in that first round pretty bad.
I was like,
she's a dangerous fight.
Yes,
Amanda Nunez is dangerous,
but if you all were all wrong,
all wrong.
If you go back and if the fight is what really threw me off,
I agree.
Her previous experiences and previous fights,
I was like,
ah,
I don't really see it.
She let it go.
Go back and look at Qualys resume like,
oh fuck yeah man.
Fuck yeah.
When she was bouncing around in the octagon to,
you're like,
this is like,
she's just like cut some serious movement.
You know?
There
was no one that she's been robbed that ever fought the talk that compare her to
like Alexis Davis.
I mean,
there's just no comparison in the movement.
No,
she made Sarah McMahon looked like a tortoise.
You know what I'm saying?
Like chief,
why Sam Mcmahon's like a tank,
you know,
she didn't even try to hide it.
She came right in the ring.
She showed exactly what she was going to do the entire time.
She always does.
She's coming in while they're doing the,
the name call outs.
She's like,
I'm going to be going left and right.
When Rhonda went to thrill that left hook and she just and ran to the cage,
she turns around like,
what the fuck?
She was already made trays,
the fucking matrix.
She was already in trouble.
She had chameleon like eyes are here like fucking,
Oh God.
Oh,
it's not snowflake.
It's weird for the world to see that.
But I think like we're saying like ultimately,
I think for martial arts it's good because you have to know that you got to have
all your ducks in order and you have to know that you got to be able to do
everything at the high friends and stay humble.
Stay thirsty.
My friend.
Stay humble motherfuckers.
Yeah.
Otherwise you're gonna get kicked into humbleness,
but there's a lot of money and not being just going to say,
I was about to say they're at,
they'll Conor McGregor,
he talked some shit,
but after the fight they,
he gives respect and he's humble.
Rollicking guys like he's a great champion.
You know,
this guy has great skills.
Ron does not like that,
man.
That's why everyone these means,
and I'll ship coming out.
Even Floyd Mayweather is humble after.
He's like,
dude,
he's a great fighter,
man.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what you're saying.
What does that,
what does that from I think,
I think it's uh,
uh,
this anger that she has to fight with this,
this whole that she's had since losing her dad.
It's just this dark darkness.
You know what I'm saying?
It's tough,
man.
Dude just killed my day.
He just went there and I just went there.
That's dark shit gets real.
It's like for martial artists though,
when you watch that fight is such an important lesson that regardless of hype,
regardless of past accomplishments,
regardless of of past performances that have looked spectacular,
got to analyze all the movement,
especially in the u s everything.
Especially when you see like boxing,
you can start off a round or two.
You might see a box to go down four rounds,
whatever,
and they come back in the UFC.
There is no,
all right,
I'm going to figure it out.
No Man,
especially got a world class level.
They're going to Merck you out.
There's so many ways to lose room.
There's some room for error at that level.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It's pretty crazy.
Pretty crazy to watch such a shift,
like a changing,
not just a changing of the guards,
but like Gosh,
just a shifting of reality.
Is there a Duane Ludwig of wrestling,
a guy who's a taken dudes that weren't that good at wrestling and now they're
just taking Easter bowling,
bowling,
muscle farm.
Jim leasers great.
It did.
Tj Dillashaw there now,
uh,
Neil Magnus,
he's got to get on the wrestling that year off.
Should be restless.
A bunch of guys.
Kenny Johnson.
There's a ton of good guys.
Yeah,
a lot a lot of people could help her with,
but all she sent in had a good point about her knees though.
Adoptation man.
I mean,
everyone's different.
If you've got bad,
like Rhonda can't do regard.
She doesn't do roadwork.
No.
Like you see a jog on the sand,
but she can't jump on the road and do work to the fucker needs up.
Wow.
Do you think she'd been doing judo since she was in diapers?
That's some shit,
man.
The hall,
they're tossing all the knee movement had a body that I was shredded knee from
judo.
Judo is gnarly man and [inaudible] especially doing that.
Her level what?
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Well wonder if they could get that stem cell shit.
Shoot it in there.
I'm shopping back up.
It's going to be very interesting times because Holly's also 34 so you've got to
think like how much longer can she compete at this level?
Like without any performance enhancing drugs.
Let's just be honest,
right?
That when you start hitting the thirties it starts to wane.
The body stops.
Especially with experience.
Yeah,
like when we were kids,
boxers,
when they would hit like 34 35 it was over five,
no NFL running backs.
As soon as they hit 30 game over that.
If you,
if you're 28 they're little sketchy 30th 30 year.
You're taking a back to the shed.
But what's crazy is that because of the damage that you take?
Yeah,
man.
All the wear and tear after 30 it never works out after a couple of knee
surgeries and you're running back.
That's why there's been so many scrambling quarterbacks that they come into the
NFL and this one's going to scramble his way to a super bowl and they're
scramblers are hard like Michael Vick.
But then they get hurt once they hit her twice and now they can't scramble.
Now they're forced to throw in the pocket.
Then they're,
the career's falling apart.
What's going to be interesting to see it in the UFC after,
if,
let's say Rhonda would just be like,
you know what?
Fuck this noise on Mount.
I got so much money on scrooge McDuck of girls.
So he,
she,
she pieces out,
you know what I'm saying?
What happens to women's MMA?
Because you can paint it how you want,
but there's no,
Rhonda made women's MMA.
She's a superstar.
There's no other headline like her.
No,
no,
nope,
nope.
You can't have pages,
a main event on a pay per view,
which never happened against Johannah.
No,
that's not a main event.
That's not going to sell.
First of all,
what I said about Rhonda.
No,
they didn't [inaudible] since day one.
Hey,
it's doesn't have the kind of skills that Rhonda has yet.
She didn't have the finish rate.
She should have my x factor.
She might be able to develop those cause she's really young and she's only been
fighting for a short amount of time.
I mean,
Paige,
she's,
she's very scrappy.
She's very attractive too,
which is a plus.
She tries,
she trains hard.
She fights hard.
She's not Ronda Rousey.
Not yet,
but she could beat,
I'm just saying right now,
if Rhonda dips out,
Holly Holm versus Miesha Tate,
it's a co main event.
There's a dude as a main event.
There's no one,
no other girl right now who would carry a paper view cart batshit crazy thing.
Holly Cow.
You're crazy.
Carry a card right now.
A page vans that will be,
uh,
that could have line of show that may fight night.
You don't think Misha Tate versus Holly Holm could,
could headline of paper view?
Not at all.
What about,
what's it called?
I think that's a Komito of any aggressive about Cyborg.
Holly Holm.
I thought.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's a main event.
But does the general public knows Cyborg?
That's what I'm saying.
They could change that real quick.
No,
we can't see.
Throw out the marketing machine.
Boom.
They got so much power they could blow cyborg dog.
Fuck disagree.
He want to go deep with the marketing.
Do you mention the fact that cyborgs tested positive for stuff?
The media,
the media is going to find out and just,
I mean cause if you have cyber listen Cyberhair you don't make it like,
like this isn't that more enticing but with her looks that's rocky slope by that
then you're like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Well everybody,
me,
man,
a meat heads or some bros,
the general population.
No,
I love women Bro.
Come on Bro.
I mean when I paid for that weather girl
saying what Rhonda did for the sport,
there's no one even close.
The girls are covering right now.
But you go to like,
like Cyborg footage.
What's,
what was amazing about Cyborg?
Like when she beat Gina was how terrifying she was.
Like there was a,
was a different kind of force and that was swollen.
She was chasing down gene.
It's just,
it was a different thing.
It was scary to see.
It was a very aggressive,
powerful energy.
Now if you,
if you add that to like accusations and you show the positive test results and
then she's your chocolate quick.
Yeah.
Okay.
Then she's your champion.
When I was the women's MMA,
it goes
with six months of sprawl training.
Mike Tyson bitches.
Six months is fraud training pubs out flying knee.
You imagine how fast that girl could explode you about how she explodes off the
line.
Like two tennis.
They have to explode,
left and explode,
right?
Coordination.
Teach her a flying knee.
Oh,
Chabot launches through the air.
Boom.
Not asked us 10 minutes behind you doing fucking sick.
I wish,
man.
I'm just saying women's MMA,
if Rhonda pieces out has a long ways to go.
Right,
and Cyborg isn't your answer to champ.
It kills women's MMA for a little bit out there and Holly doesn't have the
personality to carry the torch.
I think she has that Randy couture personality that thinks she can agree with.
There's room for that.
There's room for that great American good girl that everyone's going to be
behind that who's an amazing,
the best striker.
Chris Weidman is that guy.
Why then,
why isn't Chris Weidman?
Chris Weidman did knock out Ronda Rousey.
You know,
it's not the same thing.
If there was some male version of Ronda Rousey,
there was like fuck the world.
You know some like Judy Browning type character,
a world champion and the third one you brought out Judy Brown.
I'm just saying a male version of that like or brash,
like aggressive,
but they would have to be really good too.
That was like dragging.
Andy would have to be undefeated smashing.
It would have to be like a new entity.
[inaudible] male.
Ronda Rousey's knocked down and just flat and Jon Jones,
Chris Weidman would be fucking King of the world.
He wants to fight Jon Jones.
You asked.
What's interesting is like,
like I said,
he's like one 90 something now.
Like one 93 tough eating,
right?
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Like a wonder what's without fight might not happen because John's getting
bigger and Chris is getting smaller,
so Chris goes to welterweight.
Look,
Lord,
good luck.
Everybody wanted to see those pictures of him at one 90 minutes.
I know that'd be really skinny for,
I would imagine as he was walking,
he was a baby.
I mean,
it's such a freak.
Such a beast.
He's a beast and he liked John Jones,
grew up with his brother beating the fuck out of them.
That's a big factor with a lot of fighters.
You're in competition in the house all the time.
I was,
you know my record against my brother.
I was one out of 3000 just a Shitty,
shitty record that just beat the brakes off me all the time.
We had to go to anger management.
He got so bad.
Oh yeah.
That's so funny because you're so tight now.
It's funny.
Yeah,
we're super tight.
That's just how that works.
Like that he's a serial killer.
Others have issues like that.
So like Matt Hughes and his brother,
you still look the same.
They looked exactly like each other and they would beat the fuck out of each
other.
Look at John Jones.
His two brothers are straight freaks ones.
One of the best players in the NFL.
My brother,
my brother fucked me up.
He would,
uh,
I would have to be a slave.
He was four years older than me and like when he was swelled,
I was eight and my mom in a summer vacation,
I was the remote control.
I turned off the lights.
Are you guys close now?
We're cool.
Yeah.
That was just like,
we're quick.
No,
no,
we're,
we're great.
I like,
Tufts is going to suck.
If you beat your brother up and your brother becomes a martial arts champion and
you're like,
shit,
he's a blue belt.
Whatever.
Clinic.
Costa Mesa.
A little bit of a stout sock me 10 times in the shoulder for every time I'd far,
he could fart anytime he wanted,
but if I farted I'd have to take socks to the shoulder.
Wow.
How rude.
He is a bully.
Weird FARC Games.
Eddie like to punish friends,
so he's farting on purpose.
Here we go.
Oh,
fart battles brother and sister far paddles.
You brothers or sisters been
yeah.
Yeah.
I got a three brothers.
I actually got a twin fraternal twins.
I don't know that.
Yeah,
he's a,
he doesn't do martial arts.
He's actually extremely passive on the physical level.
Buddy.
He was in new,
like a,
um,
politics and whatnot.
He was a man.
I forget what it is.
Is He for House of Representatives out in Florida?
Um,
so on a political and verbal level,
he,
he was always the guy that would like sit there and run his mouth and I would
get angry and emotional and punch holes.
He physically,
physically,
I mean he's tall too.
Uh,
um,
I'm more,
more,
more built.
Uh,
but I definitely have my older brother,
you know,
do karate and then try damn spinning back kicks on me and fucking random shit.
Hey,
did you stand right there?
No way,
dude.
Dick,
what an asshole.
Yeah,
that's why you can't leave boys alone.
Weird shit to each other.
Then they cover up the crime.
Oh yeah.
How did he get buried?
How men died and shit.
But it's,
it's amazing.
Like Jon Jones,
right.
Grows up with two super athlete brothers.
All three of them beat the fuck out of each other.
Sisters picked on her.
Yeah.
There you go.
Isn't that interesting how that works like that?
It's interesting.
Like the,
the,
like Weidman.
I don't think Weidman,
I shouldn't talk in this cause I don't know.
But I know he was,
he had fights with his brother.
I don't think we talk too much anymore.
I bet that Maghera twins are totally tight.
They seem like different,
right?
Yeah.
They seem a different,
they don't seem like,
but what do we know?
It seemed like they bang chicks together.
Drone.
Yeah.
You wish I could see them now kicking off there a moment up to the Cabana in
their gies
that's my Guac.
Yeah.
Oh,
you big nugget.
A little nod.
You tell me you're on that
same note.
It's one of them nods.
I don't know who it was and I sure,
so you're a band.
You're on the Boston card.
Yeah.
That's a good card.
Really.
Tj Dillashaw a fight with him.
I'm not hinting Brown cruise.
Dominick Cruz had a big,
big,
huge big fight.
Just crazy for Dominic.
He's fun injuries.
How I,
how I show up,
Dominic makes to the fight.
I'm curious to see how that fight goes down until January.
That's a whole month of training.
A long time and crazy fight.
Holy Shit.
Fuck people up.
Fight like that.
That it's going to boost,
you know,
meeting Hannah Brow Art.
The U s really didn't know who he was.
So like,
all right,
cool.
We know he's a big underdog,
but Dominick Cruz,
granted he's been out of the limelight.
He's off mother Fucker,
man.
He is.
And God damn.
How good a Dominick Cruz look in that mirror.
[inaudible] fight scene came back for Ashley.
Met with Damon.
He beat the shit and Tj looks sensational in the Borow rematch.
Like God's son you got oh yeah.
Anthony Pettis.
Eddie Alvarez.
Oh,
Sharon Brown.
Mitre owns a piece of shit.
Boat Herman.
Oh my gosh.
The main card,
so forth.
Older Detroit Star.
I love watching Dj Cruickshank.
Holy Shit.
Chuck Pierce.
Mitch at Patrick coattails fighting Bro.
That uh,
that Rosa [inaudible] is ridiculous.
That's a good fight.
Yeah.
Everyone keeps saying it could be a paper view.
A man is Coronado and Ross Pearson pro.
This is a finite,
yeah,
no,
this is fun.
One Shit Dude,
are you,
she was on the undercard Yup.
First fight man.
And now as he fights them off as a bad mother fucker.
Dude,
dude,
this is this,
this should be a pay per view card.
That's a great advice.
Stack Channel Fox or Fox sports one.
I think this is Fox sports one.
Is it hard
because they made it a um,
a world title fight.
So decided to have a really strong undercard to back it.
That field from Charles.
A motherfucker wasn't supposed to do this fight.
This was like last minute.
They uh,
not last minute obviously,
cause it's not until January,
but fairly last minute they asked me to do it.
Like I wasn't scheduled to do it.
So that means that that's why I can't,
I'm not even gonna be there for the Williams.
I won't get into Saturday.
Sunday morning.
They bring in the heavy too.
He'd be like after a football game or some shit.
Dude,
hop out.
Dominick Cruz 20 and one son 20 and one who did lose to
Dominick Cruz.
Lost
cause call called WC.
WC days.
Yeah.
And then he beat him.
Corey match Rogan did with that shit.
That'd be sea sun.
That's a good fight.
It's a fight.
It's going to be interesting to see who's got like better footwork and movement.
I would assume Tj is the favorite gaming.
Yes.
Well it's because he's been an active.
Right.
That's a huge factor.
I was going to be a great fight.
Damn dollar cruising along titties.
I can't wait for pedes Alvarez.
I know,
right?
You guys come into you coming to the show.
You go to Vegas for Mcgregor.
Conor McGregor.
No,
you're not.
No.
You come to check.
You guys here is on Sunday.
You're going to be able to make it.
You're going to come back and boom.
You're not going to get in trouble with the wife or not figured out a way to
market.
It's going to be nuts.
That'd be fun,
man.
Danny Happy Cummings.
Yeah.
And you could also,
if you're not going to be there,
you could watch it on paper,
like people butoh videos.com/ebi five,
Sunday,
December 3rd 10.
If you can make it live though.
Go lots.
It's so fun to see live.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's,
it's such a exciting format.
It like really changes grappling by adding that element of putting them in bad
positions after it's over.
It's so awesome.
So far people are digging it,
man.
So far.
First four
shows have just gotten tremendous reviews.
Everyone loves it.
You know,
it's Kinda hard to have a bad show.
I mean,
it can happen,
but when you have 16 black belts and it's a tournament and you see it's like UFC
too,
you kind of hard to fuck that up with Cummings in there.
Everyone's fucking worried about his leg locks and he's right.
They're gonna fucking chainsaws way to the finals probably,
you know,
but she's got to get through.
He's got to get through a Havi honey.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
you know,
there's Raphael Domingo's,
he's a Damien Maia,
a prodigy,
uh,
Ruben Alvarez,
another leg lock.
He's an east coast leg lock.
He's from Florida with Ambrose fucks people up,
man.
And then Kim terra cow tariffs brothers in it.
Uh,
Nathan Orchard.
Fuck man.
It's,
it's gonna be crazy.
Sunday,
December 13th,
butoh videos.com.
Butoh videos.com/ebi five and and all in the first four are available.
Youtube,
their pit,
the live shows officer paper view where we're,
we're,
we're giving out 20,
uh,
last show.
Eddie Cummins won it and he got $20,000,
and that was 145 pound division that that usually doesn't happen at one 45.
So,
um,
uh,
all the money goes through the winter.
It's winner take all.
Um,
so we have to do paper view and about a month later,
a month and a half,
two months later,
I put it on Youtube and let everyone watch it.
So VIP front row is available,
reserved in general admission eight.
Like I said,
if you're in town and you're,
you're free that day,
you really should go and see it live.
Especially if you're a fan of Jujitsu at all,
you'll see the most exciting format,
digits,
a wild ass fucking fights.
And when these fights go to a draw and then they put them in bad positions at
the end,
it gets fucking nuts.
It's so fun.
It's such a great idea.
So just smart.
Just try to make it fine.
Trying to make it fun.
You know,
we got some,
we got a big things.
Planet Ebi six is going to be in Mexico City.
That's $50,000 grand prize.
Absolute division.
Damn.
So Mexico City,
boom,
Mexico.
We're going to have a real trials,
real Digi,
no trials to that in February.
And then South Bala,
we're going to go to Rio,
have trials,
Sao Paulo at trial,
son.
This is going to be,
it's family.
It's going to be nice.
That's beautiful.
It's Koper love reducing this from Televisa,
which is the huge network in Latin America.
You said kind of to
it as well.
I got that.
A Spanish accent down.
Si.
Um,
so,
uh,
that's it folks.
It's fucking things over.
Good fights,
fights.
Next time we talk,
it'll be post post,
uh,
although in Mcgregor and Weidman and Rockhold and Yo,
well Romero and Jocko,
ray and Max Holloway and Jeremy Stephens and Damien and Gunnar Nelson.
Paulk good luck can go ugly Mug Lake.
Insane.
Alright,
Ben Saunders,
MMA.
Ben,
we'll be fighting on the January card on Fox sports.
One against the lovely and talented pat code.
Tay,
uh,
Brendan Schaub.
You might know him as the fire from the fighter and the kid podcar storming
through the ranks of iTunes.
Take it out all over the world for the live shows.
Be there and he'll sing big dick band.
It's while looking to get your west coast tour tickets now,
[inaudible] dot Com sun,
plenty of,
uh,
of a gear including mugs.
He's a fighter,
official fighter and the kid mugs and tee shirts.
Lots of different tee shirts that shale and keeps jacking.
He's devious.
You know,
you're doing something right.
He's smart on youtube.
Ebi Five countdown show.
Watch that right now.
Boom.
That's it folks.
See you soon.
Much love.
Bye.
I got it.
Yeah.